mes chers abonnés pardonnez moi car j'ai
péché et pour mon incompétence
je vais devoir faire pénitence et quelle
incompétence qu'il ya même pas fichu de
faire 100 % à un test d'anatomie
comparée quoi saleté de loutres saleté
de loutres il ya que ce qu'ont vu la
vidéo qui peuvent comprendre pourquoi je
déteste les loutres donc voilà il faut
il faut que je paye il faut que je paye
et aujourd'hui du coup on va parler d'un
truc que j'ai vraiment pas envie de
faire comme d'habitude comme d'habitude
avec des bonnes kg pénitence c'est la
règle la règle numéro info que j'ai pas
envie de le faire faut que j'ai pas
envie de lire ce truc que je m'apprête à
lire la d'ailleurs je n'ai pas lu je
n'ai toujours pas lu je veux dire j'ai
lu la première phrase je me suis barré
la première fois comme l'a envoyée sauf
qu'on me l'a envoyé encore et encore
plein de fois je sais pas ce que vous
lui trouvez à ce truc là j'ai comme
l'impression que je vais pas l'aimer or
donc on va parler aujourd'hui d'une page
qui s'appelle l'évolution n'est pas
scientifique
comme par hasard un l'évolution n'est
pas scientifique pages dont bras pages
qui est quand même
catégorisé organisations religieuses 1
oui parce que la religion c'est
vachement plus scientifique le dire
voilà on va se prendre des leçons de
scientificité par une page religieuse
vous la sentez venir vous le sentez
venir que ça va être très très long et
que ça va être douloureux e
et alors c'est une page alors la
deuxième règle de des bonnes kg
pénitence et qu'il faut pas que je fasse
la promotion d'une théorie qui aurait
moins de succès que moi que moi même que
ma propre que mes propres pages donc là
sur facebook l'évolution n'est pas
scientifique izon 3700 people qui en
fait personne qui le qui aiment ça donc
c'est à peu près autant que nous sur la
page facebook donc voilà on lui fait pas
de pub en lui pas fait on lui fait pas
spécialement de pub et on pourra pas
nous accuser de deux des banques et ça
parce que on va s'accrocher à leur
succès ou quoi contrairement à si on
faisait allah m'a fâché par exemple ou
un top lan ou là typiquement on pourrait
très bien nous accuser de vouloir nous
accrocher tels des wagons à la remorque
de leur succès donc
donc on va se faire une petite page une
petite page modeste voilà
mais comme j'ai dit on m'a envoyé ça
tellement de fois que bon que il doit
forcément y avoir quelque chose je veux
dire il doit y avoir un truc
d'intéressant dedans un nom pas que non
pas que ça m'intéresse moi mais doit y
avoir quelque chose qui intéresse les
autres d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression que
dans la plupart de ses abonnés c'est
surtout des gens qui ont envie de se
moquer d'eux
quand tu regardes les commentaires
notamment tu vois que ça va être long là
un tu l'as vu là que c'était long comme
texte donc oui j'ai l'impression que
c'est vraiment des gens qui sont là pour
les trolls et quoi d'ailleurs vous avez
cédric jurassique 1 qui et qui fait
partie des des gens qui sont abonnés à
cette page donc ça veut un peu tout dire
mais bon mais bon bah on va se le faire
c'est tout c'est tout toute façon même
qu'ils aient plus ou moins de succès que
moi ça n'a pas d'importance l'important
c'est que ça ne plaise pas c'est que ce
ne soit pas intéressant je veux dire si
c'était une théorie qui avaient du
succès vous voyez quelque chose qui
attirait les foules ça m'intéresserait
pas ce que je voudrais savoir pourquoi
c'est intéressant mais là ça n'intéresse
personne
alors pourquoi je le fais mais parce que
parce qu'il faut que je paye pour mes
péchés mea culpa mea maxima culpa
je sais même plus comment on dit je n'ai
jamais fait de latin bon alors
l'évolution n'est pas scientifique je
vais me faire qu'un seul article je sais
pas si vous avez vu la taille de ce pavé
déjà je vais pas me faire toute la page
facebook un faux pas déconner et puis de
toute façon je crois qu'ils publient
plus rien la dernière publiée à date de
2019 donc je sais pas peut-être que le
coc vie de la emporté mais en tout cas
voilà alors l'évolution n'est pas
scientifique 30 juillet 2018
les fossiles de formes intermédiaires
n'existe pas alors si vous explorez un
peu la page du monsieur vous allez voir
que l'article qui vient avant sa fin le
dernier article qu'il a publié sur sa
page
c'est un truc à propos d' homo habilis
alors les fossiles de formes
intermédiaires n'existe pas enfin c'est
un fossile de apr aux cetc une un
article à propos de homo habilis c'est
pareil je n'ai pas lu mais en gros les
premières lignes c'est pour vous
expliquer que les scientifiques sont pas
d'accord pour dire si c'est un singe ou
un humain et lui il va décider que c'est
un singe parce que c'est ce qui la range
mais la raison pour laquelle les
scientifiques sont pas d'accord pour
dire si homo habilis est est un membre
du genre homo ou un membre du genre
australopithèques us parce que c'est ça
le vrai débat scientifique c'est pas est
ce que c'est un singe ou un humain
le vrai débat scientifique c est ce qu
on devrait le laisser dans le genre homo
ou est ce qu'il faudrait pas au
contraire on en fait un membre
d'australopithecus bella raisons pour ça
c'est parce que c'est une forme
intermédiaire il a des caractères qui
viennent des deux camps donc c'est pas
évident de trancher et les
paléontologues les paléoanthropologues
ont du mal à trancher parce qu'ils sont
pas vraiment adepte de la clad istiqlal
cladistique elle elle tranche
complètement elles placent homo habilis
du côté du genre homo et elle fait
d'australopithèques us à un genre par
hafid éthique donc un genre qui n'a pas
de réelle existence du point de vue
généalogie on va dire donc autant le
mettre dans le genre homo plutôt que de
le mettre dans un truc qui n'existe pas
réellement du point de vue généalogique
donc un jour australopithecus d'ailleurs
il va falloir en faire quelque chose de
généalogique généalogique mans correct
ou phylogénétiquement correct pour ceux
qui connaissent le terme
mais bon voilà c'est un autre débat donc
bref les formes les formes fossiles
n'existe enfin des formes intermédiaires
n'existe pas sauf quand j'en parle nous
dit l'évolution n'est pas scientifique
et voilà la phrase qui m'a fait
abandonner la lecture de ce truc la
première fois qu'on me l'a envoyé et la
fois suivante et la fois suivante parce
qu'on me l'a envoyé trois fois
l'évolutionnisme docteur david rope
conservateur du musée field d'histoire
naturelle à chicago dis donc voilà un
créationniste qui cite david regroupe
déjà moi ça me prend un pieu et ça me le
planter dans le coeur et comme je suis
un vampire j'aime pas ça je suis
allergique au bois surtout quand on me
le planter dans le coeur voyait david
robo vous voulez pas [ __ ] la paix à
david rossi vient de mourir le pauvre
c'est à dire c'est un scientifique il
est mort il ya pas longtemps là vous
voulez pas le laisser tranquille
regardez david robb c1 c'est un des
grands noms de la paléontologie david
europe
il est mort en 2015 donc en 2015 bon
c'est pas si récent que ça finalement
mais on avait fait une vidéo on y est on
y avait fait un petit hommage dans notre
vidéo sur la clad eastick justement à
david roch parce que c'est un des grands
noms de la paléontologie quoi c'est avec
jack jack c'est que c'est que ce qui
séduit c'est pas évident à dire avec dex
ses côtes ce qui c'est en gros il a fait
des tas de recherche sur les extinctions
de masse il a fait des tas de recherche
sur l'évolution morphologique il a fait
des tas de recherche qui est notamment
des recherches qui ont démontré que dans
toute la variété des possibles de forme
de coquille
les mollusques dans non accomplie
peut-être qu'un dixième des forme de
coquille possible ce qui veut dire qu'il
a mis en évidence grâce à ça des
contraintes phylogénétique donc et ça
pareil on en avait parlé dans une autre
vidéo donc on en a parlé plein de fois
en plus des recherches de david europe
donc je suis désolé mais moi te dire de
la merde en prenant david europe comme
est comme que enfin prendre les propos
de david europe et vouloir les détourner
comme ça pour hâter un but
créationnistes ça me
ça m'a tout de suite fait pousser des
boutons vous voyez donc bon voilà alors
on dis pas du mal de david europe
déjà pour commencer
ensuite vous admirerez qu'il fait une
citation mais qu'il ne met pas de
parenté enfin de guillemets il ne met
pas de guillemets assassinat à sa
citation
pourquoi certainement parce que parce
que les gens qui ne connaissent pas
d'avis d'europe vont s'imaginer que tout
le pavé la bla bla bla ça vient de david
regroupe noms d'abbie drop
il a probablement dit que la première
phrase et encore je suis même pas sûr la
théorie de la sélection naturelle de
darwin a toujours été étroitement lié
aux preuves provenant de fossiles et la
plupart des gens supposent probablement
qu'elle est fausse il constitue une part
très importante de l'argument général en
faveur des interprétations darwiniste de
l'histoire de la vie malheureusement
cela n'est pas strictement vrai même en
imaginant que david ropa 10 à 1 sachant
que normalement quand on écrit quand on
met une citation on dit d'où ça vient
au moins le nom du bouquin le titre de
l'article enfin histoire de pouvoir leur
trouver quoi là on peut même pas tracé
d'où ça vient et alors moi je me je
suppose qu'en fait c'est juste cette
partie là
qui est que david europe a dit la
théorie de la sélection naturelle de
darwin a toujours été étroitement lié
aux preuves provenant des fosses itil et
même là je suis pas sûr du tout parce
que je suis presque
je suis non jeu on va dire que je suis
presque certain que david rope était
tout à fait au courant que la théorie de
la sélection naturelle
surtout si on précise de darwin n'était
absolument pas lié aux preuves venant
des fossiles puisque à l'époque où
darwin a publié la première édition de
la sélection enfin de la théorie de
l'origine des espèces par la sélection
naturelle et bien les fossiles s'était
pas exactement la panacée donc les
fossiles il les avait mis gracieusement
de côté dans la première édition
après entre deux yark et opter rixe qui
a été découvert et des cris donc là on
avait enfin un truc qui pouvait faire
office de entre guillemets chaînon
manquant c'est à dire d'une espèce avec
des caractères intermédiaire entre un
groupe
les reptiles et un autre groupe les
oiseaux donc à partir de là les fossiles
ont commencé à devenir à apprendre de
l'intérêt aux yeux de darwin mais pour
darwin de toute façon il n'avait pas
besoin de ça pour expliquer l'évolution
des espèces on n'a jamais eu besoin des
fossiles pour les fossiles ne sont pas
une condition à la théorie de la
sélection naturelle
par contre ce qui a de bien avec les
fossiles c'est que à chaque fossiles
qu'on découvre on pourrait découvrir un
fossile qui dit tout le contraire de la
sélection naturelle qui dit tout
contraire de la théorie de l'évolution
on pourrait découvrir
on aurait pu par exemple découvrir après
que charles darwin est formulé sa
théorie qu'en fait les fossiles ne
documente pas du tout l'évolution qu'en
fait les fossiles sont tous les mêmes et
que dans des depuis des temps
immémoriaux homo sapiens à peupler la
terre or ce n'est pas le cas via homo
sapiens et avant ça il ya homo mais pas
sapiens donc erectus habilis etc
et puis avant ça c'est les
australopithèques et puis avance assez
ardipithecus et avant ça c'est tout
maille et chacun de ces fossiles devient
de moins en moins similaire à homo
sapiens au fur et à mesure qu'on va en
arrière dans le temps donc les fossiles
à chaque fois qu'on découvre un fossile
on pourrait en fait on fait un pari
c'est celui que oui
aller dans le sens de la théorie de
l'évolution en réalité c'est pas
forcément le cas à chaque fois qu'on
découvre à fossiles on pourrait très
bien découvrir un fossile qui dit manon
moi j'évolue pas et là je sais vous
allez me sortir le sait la coque bah oui
mais le coelacanthe jean relatifs mejia
n'a aucun fossile et ouais vous
confondez le coelacanthe jean relatifs
mejia espèces calluna et donc l'espèce
moderne de coelacanthe et laissez-la
quand c'est à dire la famille du
coelacanthe moderne et oui c'est là
quand il ya deux définitions possibles
asselah quand il ya le coelacanthe qui
est l'espèce moderne et il ya laissé là
quand qui sont les fossiles de
coelacanthe plus le coelacanthe moderne
et en l'occurrence le coelacanthe
moderne n'a pas de représentant fo si
l'on n'a pas de fossiles de coelacanthe
et les coelacanthe du passé donc ceux du
crétacé tout ça il ressemble pas tout à
fait aux coelacanthe moderne voire même
pas du tout pour certains notamment
reibel atrix par exemple il ressemble
pas du tout un coelacanthe moderne
donc voilà les fossiles
en fait les fossiles ce nom ne sont pas
une condition à la théorie de darwin
par contre ils sont un très beau test à
la théorie de darwin c'est à dire que à
chaque fois qu'on trouve un fossile et
que ce fossile ne contredit pas
l'évolution des espèces
voire même va dans le sens de
l'évolution des espèces c'est une petite
victoire pour la pour la théorie de
darwin
enfin pour la théorie de l'évolution
parce que encore une fois la théorie de
darwin tel qu'il l'a formulée il ya 150
ans elle est obsolète
aujourd'hui on est sur la synthèse de
l'évolution la synthèse de la théorie de
l'évolution
donc on n'est plus du tout sur la
théorie des telles que darwin à la
formule il ya 150 ans on a fait des
progrès quand même depuis
en bref déjà rien que cette première
phrase je suis même pas sûr que david
europe les prononcer lui-même on n'est
même pas sûr de quelle partie de cette
phrase david europe à prononcer lui-même
de toute façon donc bref c'est un appel
à l'argument d'autorité qui tombe à
l'eau et de toute façon même s'il l'a
dit même si david ropa vraiment dit ça
un jour ce qui m'étonnerait
de toute façon c'est faux enfin c'est
pas exactement vrai voilà la plupart des
gens supposent probablement qu'elle est
fausse il constitue une part très
importante de l'argument en général en
faveur de l'interprétation darwiniste de
l'origine de la vie malheureusement ce
n'est pas strictement vrai bon ben voila
voila voila ce n'est pas strictement
vrai c'est exactement ce que je viens de
vous expliquer là pour le coup peut-être
que c'est ce que réellement david
drouaud pas voulu dire c'est à dire que
oui les fossiles ne sont pas une
condition nécessaire à la théorie de
l'évolution
les fossiles viennent en plus de la
théorie de l'évolution il pourrait très
bien venir en moins de la théorie de
l'évolution mais ils ne le font pas et
c'est pour ça que c'est important les
fossiles c'est parce que ça permet de
tester la théorie de l'évolution
voilà bon donc à partir de là je pense
qu'on est plus du tout sur la citation
de david europe
là on est sur du texte purement
l'évolution n'est pas scientifique
les visiteurs d'un quelconque musée
d'histoire naturelle se retrouve face à
une intense propagande évolutionniste
non on appelle ça de l'éducation ce
serait de la propagande si on te
demander pas ton avis mais en
l'occurrence l'entrée du musée
généralement payante
et quand elle ne l'est pas il ya
personne qui t'oblige à y aller donc
c'est pas de la propagande
s'il ya personne qui t'oblige à le
regarder si on ne met pas dans ton
espace culturel commun si on s'y voit la
cité pas à un moment un peu obligé de
jamais être tombé dessus en fin de de
tomber dessus à un moment de la journée
c'est pas de la propagande ça fait voilà
ça là on efface typiquement à quelqu'un
qui voit là un enfant gâté du nom que je
suis désolé on va employer les termes je
vais déjà commencer à être méchant mais
de toute façon on sait très bien que je
vais finir par être méchant je veux dire
je ne veux pas je peux pas nous laisser
insulter de propagandistes et ne pas
devenir méchant ça commence à me gaver
déjà donc cet enfant gâté qui n'a jamais
connu un vrai bon gros régime
totalitaire à ne sais pas ce que c'est
que de la propagande
1 c'était le jour où tu vas dire le jour
où l'évolutionnisme devient une
propagande alors tu n'auras al
ça veut dire qu'on sera dans un genre de
régime politique qui ne t'autorise
rappaz a publié ce genre de chose sur
facebook un demande aux chinois demande
aux chinois ce que c'est qu'un que de la
vrai qu'un régime qui produit de la
propagande c'est pas la propagande qui
va t'en empêcher de publier par contre
le fait qu'il y ait de la propagande ça
veut dire que tu es sous un régime qui
va empêcher de publier des trucs qui
contredisent le régime propagandistes en
question voilà enfants gâtés donc non
les musées c'est pas de la propagande
tout simplement parce qu'on vous laisse
le choix d'y aller ou non personne ne
vous oblige à aller dans les musées
personnes 1 e par contre par contre vu
que c'est une organisation religieuse et
dont il se fait donc il est en train de
faire du prosélytisme antiscientifique
justement en faveur d'une religion qu'il
doit défendre je ne sais pas laquelle
mais bon voilà on va on va supposer
n'ont même pas on va rien je suppose et
on va rien supposer bref la religion
elle par contre vous demande pas votre
avis la religion elle s'impose à vous
par vos parents
généralement elle s'impose à vous par
votre éducation la religion s'impose à
vous aussi par votre environnement
culturel
vous avez certainement dans votre dans
votre lieu de résidence un gros bâtiment
qu'on appelle une église une mosquée un
temple une bref un gros bâtiment dans
lequel il y a des gens suivent un culte
on ne vous demande peut-être pas votre
avis pour aller tous les dimanches où
tous les samedis dans ce bâtiment voire
même tous les jours dans ce bâtiment
il y as peut-être des appels à la prière
qui sont lancés depuis ce bâtiment on ne
vous demande pas votre avis pour que
vous entendiez ses appels à la prière on
ne vous demande pas si vous avez envie
d'entendre ces appels à la prière on les
lance ses appels à la prière il y a
partout dans votre environnement décroît
créé des croix chrétiennes qui sont
disposés des calvaires en haut des
montagnes des croix en haut des ses
bâtiments justement des églises il ya
partout des éléments religieux dont on
vous demande et on vous demande pas
votre avis on vous les avez soulevé un
point c'est tout ça ça correspond
vachement plus à de la propagande
la seule raison pour laquelle je
n'appellerais pas ça de la propagande
c'est parce que la france est un pays où
on a une liberté de culte est donc vous
n'avez pas que une direction qui vous
est offerte
c'est à dire vous pouvez encore voir des
éléments de plusieurs religions dans
l'espace public
mais s'il n'y avait qu'une seule
religion je n'hésiterai pas si avec une
seule religion d'état je n'hésiterai pas
à appeler ça de la propagande mais ça
pour le coup c'est pas de la propagande
mais par contre ça s'en rapproche
vachement plus parce qu'on vous demande
pas votre avis contrairement au musée et
je vais prendre un exemple tout simple
c'est par exemple je suis allé au musée
de chester l'année dernière donc en
angleterre
et quand vous vous dirigez au musée de
chester et où vous attendez du coup
avoir de la science parce que non pas un
musée un le zoo pardon pas le musée le
zoo de chester quand vous vous dirigez
vers le zoo de chester et vous vous
attendez donc avoir de la science un
contenu scientifique là bas puisque
c'est quand même ça que les eaux se sont
des institutions scientifiques et bien à
l'entrée du zoo de chester vous avez
quoi une sculpture qui représente
l'arche de noé
voilà ça fait partie de ces éléments
qu'ils sont religieux qui sont là dans
votre environnement vous avez peut-être
même pas remarqué qu'il était là mais
c'est justement ça le truc de la
propagande c'est qu'au bout d'un moment
ça devient normal de voir ce genre de
choses
voilà donc non les musées ne sont pas de
la propagande donc dans ses musées sont
exposés des reconstitutions imaginaire
spéculation rationnelle je veux dire
quand on ré articule cantons rpt et
articule à un tibia avec une fibule à et
converti culte où ça en plus avec un
fémur
certes cessé de l'imagination mais ça
reste de l'imagination rationnel on est
bien d'accord
et puis quand on quand on reconstitue un
mammouth laineux avec ben et qu'on le
fait ressembler grosso modo à un
éléphant c'est pareil ça reste quand
même rationnels comme reconstitution
donc spéculation rationnelle donc je
mets je ne nie pas qu'il ya une part
d'imagination par contre donc ils sont
exposés de reconstitution imaginaire et
des photos dans des moulages des
moulages pas défaut aux eaux c'est des
vrais au conte a moulé et on en fait une
copie à l'identique fabriqués à la main
supposées appartenir à nos prétendus
ancêtres entre autres nos prétendus
ancêtres puisqu'il ya aussi des
mammouths des tigres à dents de sabre
des dinosaures et c'est le moindre
fragment d'os fossilisés d'un être ayant
vécu jadis qui ne représente en soi
nullement une preuve de l'évolution
bon bah comme j'ai dit ce c'est pas une
preuve de l'évolution mais ça pourrait
aussi être une preuve contre l'évolution
et ça ne l'est pas non plus est
toutefois présenté comme une preuve
hautement importante de formes
intermédiaires de transition imaginaire
du poisson en amphibiens ou alors la
généralisation absurde
mais bon tous les fossiles ne sont pas
des transitions entre poissons et
amphibiens elle piste host et g est une
transition entre poissons et amphibiens
si vous voulez en voir une voile à l
pisto steger ça c'est le le beau poisson
transitionnelle par excellence donc
voici le fossile original en photo ici
sur une page wikipédia que vous pouvez
voir et ici on voit un peu mieux sur une
photo prise sur twitter voit la part des
visiteurs du musée
donc c'est pas des trucs propagandiste
voici la photo qui vient de l'article
peer review v qui est paru dans knight
leur don quelle piste hausse tg c'est un
crâne d'amphibiens avec les opercules
détachées qui forment les épaules donc
tout ça là toute cette partie là le
crâne
c'est typiquement de l'amphibien je peux
même vous montrer voilà un crâne
d'amphibiens qui vient du de la période
suivante le locle elle piste host et
j'ai bien du carbonifère mais dans la
période suivante qui est le permien vous
pouvez voir le crâne d'un amphibien
voilà donc bien évidemment celui-là il
est pas très joli mais celui là par
exemple voilà vous pouvez voir le museau
arrondit les yeux sur le sommet du crâne
l'encoche aux tic qui se trouve là le
museau arrondit les yeux au sommet du
crâne l'encoche outil qui se trouve à
l'arrière
le crâne est identique à celui d'un
amphibien par contre le corps lui il est
couvert des cayes
il a une queue de poisson et il a des
nageoires avec des rayons dessus comme
un poisson
donc c'est pas mentir aux gens de dire
qu'on a des ancêtres communs donc des
espèces transit de transitionnelle entre
poissons et amphibiens
voilà
une cote qui comme une côte qui
confirmerait davantage le fait de la
création est exhibé avec une immense
fierté comme preuve de l'évolution
une côte moi je te parle pas d'une cote
moi je te parle d le pis des speeds
delpy stoos tg qui est un squelette
complet donc de où tu me sors une cote
jeu lire ça c'est une caricature d'un
mec qui n'a jamais foutu les pieds dans
un musée un visiblement ils s'imaginent
qu'effectivement on va brandir un petit
os comme ça en disant regardez c'est
l'ancêtre en commun non non non non non
non non on essaye quand même d'avoir des
trucs assez probant voyez puis bon je
vous ai montré le piston steger mais
c'est pas pour vous montrer aussi
tiktaalik ici au stella et à caen
toaster gars qui sont tous connus par
des squelettes relativement complet qui
documentent tous la transition entre
poissons et amphibiens donc non non on
n'a pas qu'une cote vous en faites pas
on est un peu mieux que ça puis encore
une fois je veux dire attribué ces
propos la route ça me fait vomir
jeudi on vous rendez compte que là on a
juste fait ça depuis
même pas un petit peu plus square nés
tous les deux maux il faut que je
m'arrête parce que tous les deux mots il
ya une connerie quoi c'est quand même
assez affligeant là alors je crois qu'on
a vraiment atteint un champion du monde
quoi je pense que même sur stop mensonge
je m'arrêtais pas tous les 2 e mo et ses
stocks mensonge à dire il n'ya pas plus
notoires comme mythomane du net que les
auteurs qui travaillent sur ce top
mensonge
enfin qui copie colle des articles sur
son top mensonge pardon bref
wouah ça fait combien de temps j'ai
commencé la maman je veux pu le faire se
basant sur les descriptions détaillées
des prétendus fossiles et les noms
latins qui leur sont attribués ce qui
examine ces pièces sont convaincus
d'avoir affaire à un évolutionniste
donc se basant sur la description
détaillée des preuves et les noms latins
qui leur sont attribués ce qui examine
les pièces a donc les visiteurs d'accord
les visiteurs sont convaincus d'avoir
affaire à un évolutionniste alors ils
ont à faire un fossile surtout
à un fai évolutionniste pardon j'avais
sauté le mot fait ils ont l'impression
d'avoir à faire un fait évolutionniste
alors définition de ce qu'est un fait
s'il vous plaît la rousse fait ah ouais
on en est on en est arrivé là du niveau
de déblocage c'est que maintenant faut
reprendre des définitions de base de
braz
alors fait nom masculin
définition acte phénomène action chose
événement qui se produit ce qui est
reconnu comme certains incontestable
tout événement susceptible de produire
des effets de droit d'avoir des
conséquences juridiques bombe à nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est vraiment ce qui
est reconnu comme certains est
incontestable l'existence delpy stoos sz
tg est reconnu comme certaines est
incontestable il est là il existe je
veux dire le fossile il est là il existe
je vais vous leur montrez un parce que
quand même voilà ceci cette image n'est
pas un fait c'est une reconstitution
ceci est le fossile ceci est un fait
voilà je hais le fait est qu'il a un
crâne d'amphibiens et un corps de
poisson
donc oui certains fossiles je ne dis pas
que tous les fossiles sont sondés des
formes transitionnelle mais certains
fossiles sont tout à fait des faits qui
soutiennent la théorie de l'évolution
or le véritable objectif du musée alors
attention quand on commence une phrase
avec le véritable objectif du musée on
est sur un gros procès d'intention 1
on sent que ce qui va venir après vous
voyez ça va piquer aux oreilles ça va
piquer donc accrochez vous 1
prenez du baume cas molle c'est très bon
pour les hémorroïdes
parce que ça va piquer le fion or le
véritable objectif du musée oui je
prends une voix dramatique pour pour le
complot parce qu'on sent venir le
complot le véritable objectif du musée
est de donner l'impression que quelque
chose existe alors qu'elle n'a jamais
existé et de faire de la propagande
à propos de quelque chose dit n'existant
bon alors le fossile il existe ça c'est
dit après tout les tous les musées du
monde si vous allez au muséum de paris
par exemple tous les musées du monde non
pas un help is toaster j'ai à vous
montrer donc ce qu'ils vont montrer
éventuellement ce sera un moulage c'est
à dire une copie conforme à l'original
du fossile del piste d'al pisto steger
mais quoi qu'il arrive il n'y a pas de
mensonge là dedans
il n'y a pas d' arnaque une copie
conforme
c'est une copie conforme voilà est
généralement d'ailleurs pour vous dire
c'est que la plupart des musées vous
préciserons sur le cartel que c'est bien
un moulage la plupart des musées vous le
diront que c'est un moulage de
l'original et que c'est pas un et que
c'est pas l'original lui même surtout
pour des fossiles très importants comme
lucy est hors de question de laisser ça
dans une vitrine dans un musée tout
simplement parce que ben on a vu par
exemple c'était en 2014 je crois il ya
un mec qui est rentré par la fenêtre du
muséum d'histoire naturelle qui acier ou
tronçonné une défense d'un des éléphants
dans la galerie voilà pour revendre
l'ivoire donc non on va pas laisser des
fossiles qui sont uniques au monde et
d'une valeur scientifique et hyper
précieuse à la merci de ce genre de
personne l'a donc non effectivement on a
tendance à pas vouloir montrer les
originaux mais par contre ça veut pas
dire qu on vous ment en vous montrant
défaut ce sont des copies conformes
donc là j'imagine que le fait le truc
inexistant c'est l'évolution voilà
quelque chose d'inexistence j'imagine
que ce qui veut dire c'est l'évolution
alors l'évolution existe-t-elle ou non
oui elle existe parce qu'on peut la voir
on voit les bactéries évolué on voit les
bactéries s'adapter aux antibiotiques on
les a vus dans un laps de temps de d'à
peine 50 ans on les a vus les moustiques
du métro de londres
on les a vus se former une spéciale sion
les a vus se séparer des mets des
moustiques qui vivent à la surface on
les voit aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
incapables de se reproduire donc il ya
deux espèces différentes maintenant les
les fameux les arts de pote marc rares
où je suis incapable de prononcer ce
truc là mais c'est les fameux les harkis
qui ont évolué en seulement trente ans
et là on a des modifications qui sont de
l'ordre du macroscopique s'est tendu de
la macro évolution c'est à dire que vous
avez un lézard qui est carnivore qui vit
sur une île qui s'appelle pote kopitz et
on a pris ce lézard carnivore il ya 30
ans enfin il ya quarante ans maintenant
parce que ça fait longtemps qu'on a
découvert ça il ya 40 ans on a pris ces
lézards de potes kopitz et on les a
lâchés sur une île
qu'ils s'appellent pod marc caro je
crois que ça se dit marc karume je suis
pas sûr quelque part dans je crois que
c'est dans les balkans cd des îles qui
sont au large des balkans on les a
lâchés sur c'est sur cette île et ces
lézards sont devenu végétarien et donc
ils ont maintenant des adaptations un
régime herbivores dont ils ont des
modifications visibles de la mâchoire
des modifications visibles du tube
digestif
donc il ya personne encore qui est allée
qui est allé jusqu'à dire c'est une
nouvelle espèce mais c'est pas parce que
la décision arbitraire de dire c'est une
nouvelle espèce n'a pas eu lieu que
c'est pas que ça n'est pas pour autant
de la macro évolution je sais pas parce
que personne n'a encore osé franchir le
pas que ce pas ne devrait pas être
franchies donc l'évolution on la voit on
est capable de la voir pendant le temps
humain voilà donc l'évolution ça existe
suivant est d'ailleurs l'évolution ça
existe tellement que je peux même vous
l'a démontré on peut démontrer que
l'évolution existe c'est ce que j'avais
écrit c'est ce que j'avais fait dans la
vidéo
l'épreuve de l'évolution en sept minutes
que je peux vous retrouvez dès
maintenant
l'épreuve de l'évolution en sept minutes
donc je vous invite à aller voir cette
vidéo la l'épreuve de l'évolution en
sept minutes c'est une vidéo en fait
tout mieux que de vous lister les
preuves de l'évolution je fais une
démonstration que l'évolution existe et
cette démonstration elle est toute
simple toute simple pour que l'évolution
n'existe pas il faut deux choses il faut
soi
pêcher le mécanisme de la mutation parce
que c'est les mutations c'est la
descendance avec modification même en
général pas seulement la mutation mais
aussi le brassage génétique qui a lieu
durant la reproduction donc il faut
empêcher le mécanisme de descendance par
mutation par modification
enfin de descendance avec modification
gens brûlent mes mots donc si vous
voulez empêcher le mécanisme de
descendance avec modification dans le
seul moyen c'est le clonage
or les êtres humains se reproduise pas
par clonage donc les êtres humains
évolué et vous pouvez prendre ça il ya
que quelques espèces qui se reproduit
par cloud qui se reproduisent par
clonage essentiellement des
unicellulaires et même chez elles on
trouve des mécanismes qui augmente la
variable la variation génétique
notamment des échanges de gènes et puis
du brassage enfin et des mutations aussi
contrôler ces des espèces qui contrôlent
leur mutation c'est ouf
mais voilà donc enfin qui contrôlent
leur taux de mutation c'est à dire
qu'ils peuvent volontairement provoqué
des mutations
c'est assez dingue mais bref
donc faut empêcher ça parce que si vous
empêchez pas la descendance avec
modification pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous êtes différent de vos parents vos
enfants sont différentes vous et leurs
enfants après eux et leurs enfants a
pris fin après eux ce qui fait que 50
génération après votre votre existence
l'humanité n'a plus rien à voir avec ce
qu est l humanité aujourd'hui et du coup
ça donne quoi
ça donne que l'uma si l'humanité les
plus la même l'humanité a changé si elle
a changé c'est qu'elle a évolué point
final
voilà donc même d'une génération à une
autre d'ailleurs l'humanité change
complètement
voilà il n'y a plus un seul génomes qui
soit le même 50 ans cinquante génération
après aujourd'hui donc voilà donc ça
c'est le premier mécanisme qu'il
faudrait empêcher c'est impossible donc
l'évolution existe deuxième mécanisme
qu'il faudra empêcher c'est le mécanisme
de la sélection naturelle qui alors
qu'ils n'empêchent pas du coup
l'évolution dont je viens de parler ce
serait une évolution qui serait
complètement aléatoire donc si vous avez
des changements qui ce qui se situe dans
tous les sens vous avez que des
mutations et que du brassage génétique
c'est des changements qui sont
complètement aléatoire maintenant si
vous
de l'adaptation si vous voulez qu'il y
ait une évolution qui s'adapte à un
environnement donné il faudrait empêcher
la sélection naturelle et empêcher la
sélection naturelle ça veut dire tous se
reproduire et même déjà tous survivre
complètement au hasard et survivre à
avoir sa survie complètement dépendante
du hasard
ça n'existe pas ou alors il faudrait
convives sous une pluie constante de
météorites qui tomberait au pif et puis
ben on verrait bien qui survit je veux
dire c'est le seul moyen
or notre survie n'est rarement dû à
notre hasard au hasard donc enfin n'est
jamais dû au hasard la survie et encore
moins la reproduction je veux dire vous
prenez la décision de faire des enfants
donc c'est pas une décision fait au
hasard donc voilà ça c'est toute façon
le hasard de la reproduction n'existe
pas puisque généralement vous allez vous
reproduire avec votre voisin
enfin avec au moins quelqu'un qui habite
près de chez vous donc général donc de
base ça exclut à peu près tous les
chinois ça exclut tous les australiens
ça exclut tous les sud américains je
veux dire voilà donc donc c'est pareil
ça n'existe pas un monde sans sélection
naturelle ça n'existe absolument pas et
pour finir de toute façon comment
l'évolution ne pourraient-elles ne pas
exister alors que le climat change que
les continents bouge que il y a des
enfin je veux dire que tout change dans
notre environnement
absolument tous les saisons changent les
le niveau d'ensoleillement changeant
constamment enfin je veux dire l'axé de
rotation de la terre change il ya des
glaciations même des fois juste comment
voulez vous que les espèces reste
constante dans un monde dans un monde
qui change tout le temps
les espèces ne peuvent pas rester
constante autrement elles ne peuvent pas
s'adapter
forcément il faut qu'il ya un mécanisme
derrière cette adaptation est ce
mécanisme
c'est l'évolution voilà donc donc on
peut démontrer que l'évolution existe je
veux dire là c'est pas des spéculations
que je vous donne le monde change
c'est une affirmation elle est prouvée
le monde change
comment les espèces s'adaptent si elles
ne changent pas aussi point
d'interrogation
la réponse est qu'elles ne peuvent pas
les mutations au lieu le brassage
génétique a lieu ce sont des choses
vérifiables et vérifier comment une
espèce peut rester la même
alors que ces gènes change constamment
d'une génération à l'autre
réponse est ça ne peut pas les espèces
évoluent
nal
et la sélection naturelle existe
pourquoi parce que on meurt pas au pif
on meurt pour des raisons généralement
soit des maladies soient des accidents
des accidents qui sont pas dus au hasard
qu'ils sont si vous avez un accident de
voiture par exemple c'est que vous
n'avez pas vu venir la bagnole d'en face
si vous l'avez pas vu venir ça dépend
des de votre vue voilà ça dépend des de
votre attention donc des capacités de
votre cerveau ça dépend des deux voilà
c'est pas du hasard pur et dur c'est pas
du hasard comme une météorite qui vous
tombe dessus alors que vous êtes sorti
de chez vous voilà mais ça ça n'arrive
jamais enfin très peu évidemment vous
allez mettre maintenant une suis sûr
qu'il y en a déjà dans les commentaires
en train de me mettre l'exemple de ce
mec qui s'est fait beaucoup musi et la
tronche par une météorite
oui merci il y en a un tous des 150 ans
est pas voilà donc dire que l'évolution
n'existe pas c'est une connerie dire que
les fossiles n'existe pas c'est une plus
grosse connerie
les évolutionnistes s'imagine atteindre
leur but à travers ses méthodes parce
que les visiteurs de musées n'ont pas
conscience du fait qu'il n'existe pas un
seul faux cils de formes intermédiaires
pour soutenir la théorie de l'évolution
bah j'ai déjà cité archéoptéryx donc mis
dinosaures me one au jeu j'ai déjà cité
el piste host et gémit amphibiens mi
poisson
nous pouvons aussi j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure d'homo habilis qui a une
mâchoire de plus réduite beaucoup plus
réduite qu'un singe donc beaucoup plus
proches de l'homme moderne mais un
cerveau beaucoup plus petit que celui de
l'homme moderne donc beaucoup plus
proche de celui du sage temps faut
combien c'est là la question c'est même
pas le sait même pas est ce que ça
existe la question c'est y temps font
combien de forme transitionnelle avant
que tu admettre voilà j'ai j'avais fait
une vidéo voilà je peux aussi vous vous
la montrer les les espèces
intermédiaires existent
intermédiaires existent donc vidéo je
parlais d'un petit d'un petit animal qui
s'appelle dire troc nature et donc dire
trop de natus il a une mâchoire qui est
à moitié
littéralement à moitié celle d'un
reptile est à moitié celle d'un
mammifère il a les deux types de
mâchoire en même temps voilà vous voulez
quoi de plus un intermédiaire que ça
donc si vous voulez tout savoir sur dire
trop de natus c'est cette vidéo les
espèces intermédiaires existent donc
évidemment lui ce qu'il veut c'est à une
forme de transition qu'ils soient
absolument parfaite donc c'est à dire
une je sais pas une grenouille avec une
queue de poisson m'avait mais ça ça
n'existe pas ça n'existera jamais et les
évolutionnistes c est la partie qui est
très importante surtout c'est les
évolutionnistes jamais n'ont imaginé que
ça pouvait exister c'est surtout ça
d'ailleurs si tu veux une grenouille
avec une queue de poisson au passage
regarde un têtard bon je dis ça j'ai à
dire ces formes de transition elles sont
tellement enfin ça existe les formes de
transition
ça existe et j'ai presque et j'ai envie
de dire de réhabiliter le terme chaînon
manquant parce que le terme chaînon
manquant c'est à terme que les gens les
gens l'aiment pas du tout enfin les
évolutionnistes n'aime pas du tout parce
que parce qu'ils véhiculent l'idée d'une
chaîne donc l'idée d'un changement
linéaire or on sait que l'évolution
c'est quand même un peu plus compliqué
que ça mais il ya quand même l'idée
d'espèces intermédiaire dans chaînon
manquant qui je pense mérite la
réhabilitation du terme chaînon manquant
temps qu'on donne une bonne définition
voilà bref tant qu'on rend tant que la
définition qu'on utilise du terme
chaînon manquant est très clair voilà
dans les contenus qu'on produit ils ne
savent pas non plus que les fossiles
vivants resté identique pendant des
millions d'années contrairement aux
affirmations de la théorie de
l'évolution sont dissimulés dans les
entrepôts situés souvent ironiquement en
dessous des salles d'exposition c'est
tellement une énorme connerie
alors c'est là quand museum
je l'écris en anglais pour avoir encore
plus de réponses voilà donc l'ati mejia
calluna et vous voyez dans un musée dans
un musée à east london dans en afrique
du sud pour le coup donc c'est là en
plus c'est une ça doit être le
coelacanthe original celui qui a été
retrouvé en 1938 pour le coup vous le
voyez ici exposée au musée de east
london avec son petit cartels
explicatifs avec des petites têtes de
gens derrière qui dépassent des reflet
dans le miroir bref il est exposé dans
un musée
l'ati mejia calluna est encore une fois
un coelacanthe exposé dans une vitrine
de musée quoi d'autre un jeune garçon en
train de visiter un musée c'est le même
c'est celui de east london une un autre
cartel de coelacanthe celui du
smithsonian maintenant il ya un peu
vieux celui-là mais j'imagine qu'ils ont
un plus récent maintenant vous voyez
encore des enfants en train de regarder
une image du coelacanthe dans un musée
tu as ta au moins eu vaguement un petit
peu de curiosité avant d'écrire ta
connerie je veux dire
est ce qu'on en a à paris je me rappelle
plus est ce qu'il ya un coelacanthe
exposé à paris coelacanthe mnhn pour
muséum d'histoire naturelle muséum
national d'histoire naturelle de paris
au muséum national d'histoire naturelle
de paris où ils ont même une équipe qui
fait de la recherche active sur le
coelacanthe bon voilà encore un exemple
voilà la sphère du coelacanthe exposée
au muséum d'histoire naturelle de paris
apparemment donc va chier non là je ne
peux pas être plus que mal peu je peux
pas être plus polie que ça c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible de dire dans
la connerie à ce point là donc non on ne
vous cache pas l'existence des fossiles
vivants je veux dire le coelacanthe
c'est le fossile vivant par excellence
même si comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
c'est un peu abusif d'appeler cela un
fossile vivant
vu qu'il ya pas de fossiles de lahti
mejia donc bon mais c'est lui quand même
le fossile par excellence je lire je
peux même limule limule mnhn
voilà donc la est-ce qu'ils ont des nids
mule à paris peut-être pas à paris enfin
limule donc on va écrire horseshoe crabe
museum
anshu crabe museum donc limule musée
j'écris ça comme un corps et en plus
alors vous voyez là je veux dire vous
avez même tout le développement de la
limule exposée dans un musée
voilà vous avez magnifique exposition de
limur il est assez gros lamont fossiles
vivants ou tu le vois toujours pas non
mais sérieusement à mon dieu on nous
cache la vérité
[Rires]
saka me saka mais en fait les efforts
déployés par les évolutionnistes s'avère
être creux bah merde on a on a
complètement échoué regardez ils savent
en libye mule
moi j'ai perdu ma ligne merde dit non à
des efforts de tous azimuts
j'ai perdu ma ligne
en fait les efforts d
liés par les évolutionnistes s'avère
être creux aucun fossile de forme avait
un intermédiaire et ayant le concept
d'évolution n'a jamais été découvert à
part archéoptéryx à paris ce taux steger
à part les australopithèques et homo
habilis à par appareil qui est également
testé gains par le chagrin quand ça fait
aussi partie des formes intermédiaires
puisque c'est un poisson à nageoires
charnue voilà il n'existe en effet pas
la moindre trace de ces étranges
créatures imaginaires semi développés
qui aurait dû exister au cours des
millions d'années le processus je veux
pas encore inciter la liste que je ne
citais ça suffit le processus
d'évolution n'est rien de plus qu'une
croyance
encore une fois je suis sûr que tu as
des choses à nous apprendre sur ce qui
est une croyance et ceux qui n'en est
pas clin d'oeil clin d'oeil un souhait
que les évolutionnistes voudrait voir se
vérifier pour quelle raison de dire
qu'est ce que cela nous apporterait
d'avoir l'évolution qu'est ce que ça
nous apporterait honnêtement 1 2 je ne
vois pas je vois pas en tout cas pas
l'argent ni la gloire ça je peux
témoigner en tant que paléontologues
l'argent la gloire on n'a pas ça c'est
sûr le pouvoir non l'a pas non plus tout
au plus on a le pouvoir de faire faire
nos devoirs nos étudiants et encore il y
en a plein qui rendent jamais leur copie
donc bon
pourtant les archives fossiles n'ont
jamais permis à ce rêve de devenir vrai
[ __ ] faut vraiment faut vraiment pas
avoir google et chaînon manquant un nom
mais voilà je suis obligé d'en venir là
il faut vraiment jamais avoir google et
chaînon encore pour
pour en venir à des trucs pareils quoi
bon faut dire qu'en même temps quand on
google chaînon manquant on trouve
beaucoup de conneries un waro bon alors
on va peut-être préciser fossiles avec
chaînon manquant parce que l'avs
apparemment le concept de chaînon
manquant a été largement pollué par par
la culture
voilà donc chaînon manquant voici ida
qui a été vendu comme un chaînon
manquant alors bon saana d'api des c'est
pas vraiment le meilleur exemple voici
archéoptéryx évidemment donc celui-là je
les ai vus en vrai d'ailleurs celui là
c'est la photo du vrai le spécimen de
berlin c'est pas une n'est pas une copie
un australopithèque ici vous harry
intéressant ici ici vous avez la cage
thoracique d'un truc qui s'appelle et or
un coq et lis donc qui est à une forme
intermédiaire entre les reptiles oiseaux
et des tortues
le problème c'est que pour une raison
que j'ignore ils nous montrent que la
cage thoracique mais bref et or un coq
ellis c1
c'est un genre de reptiles comme une
auto au russe qui a une cage thoracique
très courtes très cylindrique avec des
cotes très écartés or on sait que les
tortues moderne est long des côtes très
écartés mais au point qu'elles sont
toutes fusionner en traite et sa forme
la carapace le fait qu'elle soit ou de
fusionner entre elles
donc et or un coq ellis ca les armes
tout d'un lézard à part que ça une demie
carapace de tortue une carapace de
tortue qui n'est pas encore complètement
formée donc une magnifique formes
intermédiaires un beau chaînon manquant
comme on n'en fait plus et puis si on
continue de descendre et bien on va
trouver on va trouver ici un petit ça
doit être un paléo terium c'est à dire
un ancêtre des chevaux donc qui était
tout petit et qui avait quatre doigts
aux pattes
au lieu d'avoir au lieu d'être comme les
chevaux très grand avec un seul doigt ou
pâtes donc forme intermédiaire entre les
mammifères bazzo et les chevaux moderne
toumaï évidemment le plus ancien
hominidé connu continueront à scroller
le fameux et lepisto steger que voici
que voilà
magnifique d'ailleurs encore une fois à
ça c'est le fossile original c'est pas
une copie c'est pas c'est pas un fou
on continue de descendre alors on va
retrouver un dernier justin dernier
histoire de histoire de faire bonne
mesure est ce qu'on peut trouver autre
chose
est ce qu'on va trouver autre chose ah
mais oui oui ça ce serait bien qu'il en
montre justement là le fossile de
sbeitla alors attendez
me araignée machin oui mais il donne pas
le nombre de bêtes
j'aurais bien aimé avoir le monde ce
bête milliard et niemi scorpions donc ça
à fossiles qui est intéressant parce que
justement il est mis à renier me
scorpions ça comme ça ça donnera un
exemple un peu d'un chaînon manquant
d'un chaînon manquant invertébrés pour
une fois donc mis à renier me scorpion
sur maxisciences ils doivent donner le
nom scientifique de ce tome est à bah
voilà le voilà tac tac tac tac tac
donc voilà ça un truc milliard et niemi
scorpions alors pourquoi il est mis à
renier me scorpions parce que vous voyez
de très bien la ressemblance en fait la
partie antérieure ressemble beaucoup à
une araignée je veux dire le semblant
c'est assez flagrante il ya huit pattes
vous avez ici ce sont pas les pattes
mais ce sont les kelly sert donc c'est
ce qui va donner les passe chez les
scorpions est ce qu'il va donner les
crochets chez les araignées donc là vous
voyez que c'est ni l'un ni l'autre en
fait donc c'est encore dans sa forme
indifférenciée donc ce qui est très très
très chaînon manquant risque si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi mais on voit surtout
que l'abdomen
au lieu d'être une seule boule comme
chez les araignées l'abdomen et encore
segmenté en petits morceaux là vous
voyez un deux trois quatre et c est
cette abdomen segmenté bas c'est comme
chez les scorpions c'est ce qui va
donner un ultime en la que des scorpions
et vous avez même un petit elles sont
ici pareil qui va donner le dard de la
queue des scorpions donc voilà leur
constitution de la bête quand elle était
vivante on voit la partie antérieure qui
est celle qui est très similaire à une
araignée mais la partie postérieure qui
est encore segmenté avec un long tail
son qui deviendra un jour là que et le
dard du scorpion voilà voilà pour les
chaînons manquants qui n'existe pas mais
qui n'existe je veux dire vous en plus
l'appareil vous avez vu le fossile
originel dans l'ombre magnifiquement
préservé il n'y a aucun doute quant à
son interprétation
jeunes ou l'art mais juste pour le
plaisir des yeux je vais vous la
remettre parce que quand même je trouve
qu'il est super classe ce fossile
sauf si je n'arrive pas à retrouver la
page évidemment donc voilà je vous la
remet pour le plaisir des yeux on peut
voir que c'est préserver dans l'ombre
qui a pas de doute quant à
l'interprétation de ce truc je veux dire
c'est pas eu
c'est pas comme il disait tout à l'heure
c'est pas juste une côte qui se balade
comme ça et que et qu' il faut de
l'imagination pour pouvoir les
interpréter non je suis désolé là on
voit très bien
huit pattes le corps d'araignée la
partie segmenter les kelly serre qui
sont pas différencier va te faire [ __ ]
va te faire [ __ ] je ne saurais mieux
exprimer mon mépris d'innombrables
fossiles ont été exhumés dans le monde
entier sans que des fossiles de formes
intermédiaires manquantes ne soit
découvert à leur tour
ben si si si alors après c'est pareil si
l'évolution n'existe pas pourquoi il ya
des trilobites veux dire c'est quoi les
trilobites du coup c'est des trucs qui
parce que c'est bien joli de dire les
espèces n'ont jamais changé tout ce qui
existe aujourd'hui c'est ça a toujours
existé mais du coup tout ce qui a
disparu ça vient d'où c'est les espèces
que dieu n'existait pas que que dieu
n'aimait pas c'est ce et voilà les
trilobites sur tout les trilobites il
vivait dans l'eau alors comment ils se
sont retrouvés morts pendant le déluge
parce que je le sens les scuds je la
sens venir l'excusent du déluge mais des
trilobites c'était aquatique et puis ça
voilà et puis pourtant bains sont quand
même disparu alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec eux 1 il est impossible qu'on
en trouve la moindre trace car
l'évolution n'a jamais eu lieu donc là
c'est là on est au niveau négationnisme
un total je veux dire de la tout ça
c'était du négationnisme jusqu'à présent
c'est je veux dire on y littéralement
l'épreuve en inventant des théories
fictive en fabriquant des formes
intermédiaires imaginaire en pl dhr en
plâtre en bakélite et en élaborant des
reconstitutions basé sur les influences
de l'artiste pour illustrer des vies
supposé de format intermédiaire
attention le complot arrivent les
darwinistes cherche à insuffler la vie à
une prétendue évolution ben non on n'a
pas besoin parce que nos fossiles
s'interprète déjà très bien tout seul
n'a même pas besoin d'une vue d'artiste
là ça se fait tout seul allah et puis si
on prend archéoptéryx par exemple harkat
et au thé rixe marque et aubeterre x
c'est pareil s'interprète tout seuls n'y
a pas besoin d'être paléontologues
regarde moi ça alors regarde ça voilà
mais toi bien
regarde bien alors tu caches les plumes
tu caches les plumes avec tes mains tu
mais voilà les mains comme ça sur
l'écran pour cacher les plumes des ailes
qu'est ce que tu vois tu vois des longs
doigts tu vois des griffes
tu regardes le petit crâne tu vois des
dents bon alors fausse ou méformes et on
les voit quand même les dents juste là
tu regardes la queue elle est super
longue ça a rien à voir avec un oiseau
et pourtant tu enlève tes mains pouf et
tu vois quoi des plumes
donc c'est un squelette de dinosaure
avec des plumes d'oiseaux
vas-y fais la chorégraphie avec moi
squelettes de dinosaures plumes
d'oiseaux
là des dinosaures à plumes d'oiseaux
heureusement que l'image est petit en
bas à droite parce que parce que j'aurai
vraiment l'air ridicule d'en arriver à
des niveaux paris donc voilà
archéoptéryx c'est un squelette de
dinosaure avec des plumes d'oiseaux
ça c'est pas plus compliqué à
interpréter comme ça ça a des dents ça a
des griffes saadé doit séparer ça une
longue que ça tibia fibula qui sont pas
fusionner sur ce spécimen nasa se voit
pas mais sur le spécimen de londres on
voit même la fourchette
nafi recul à turku là qu'on retrouve
chez les dinosaures et chez les oiseaux
donc il faut arrêter
il faut arrêter de dire de la merde
l'oeuf était un pur celui qui se soucie
encore défait arriver à ce niveau-là de
l'article ne fait-elle toutefois que
leurs efforts ne porteront jamais leurs
fruits
bave cs est hélas extrêmement triste à
dire mais oui c'est vrai on pisse dans
un violon nous autres évolutionniste
j'ai fait des recherches pour une vidéo
qui devrait sortir il ya quelques temps
mais j'ai fait des recherches en gros il
ya qu' il n'y a qu'une trentaine de pays
il ya 200 pays dans le monde en gros et
ya qu une trentaine de pays chez qui
plus de 50% de la population croît en
l'évolution donc toi
[ __ ] de créationnistes qui croient
qu'ils croient qu'il ya un complot
évolutionniste pour que le monde entier
croit à l évolution
sache que non en fait c'est c'est plutôt
la minorité en fait les évolutionnistes
est une très grand c'est une très large
minorité 1
là on parle de moins de 15% des pays
dans le monde où plus de 50% par lh2
enfin où plus de 50 % de la population
pense que l'évolution est vrai donc
donc oui là pour le coup le fait est
toutefois que leurs efforts ne porteront
jamais leurs fruits bas en tout cas
[ __ ] on a bien du mal effectivement
donc là pour une fois il dit pas une
connerie
les conditions sont aujourd'hui
différente de celle de l'époque de
darwin vrai maintenant on a accès à
internet où vous les faits scientifiques
sont dévoilées et de nouvelles
découvertes révèle constamment les
preuves du fait de la création
alors le fait de la création l'épreuve
c'est parti aucun d'art
une liste ne peut soutenir que les archi
faux cils sont insuffisantes ne peut
plus soutenir que les archives fossiles
sont insuffisantes par dont la science
et les fossiles fournissent une pléthore
de preuves incontestables deuxième fois
qu'il invente des preuves
l'absence de tout fossile intermédiaire
est trop évidente pour être couverte
plus longtemps par les évolutionnistes
absence qui n'est pas cette phrase elle
est doublement problématique cdu n'ya
pas absence de formes intermédiaires
comme je l'aï déjà démontré mais surtout
la preuve d'absence n'est pas l'absence
de problèmes non l'apprend l'absence de
preuve n'est pas preuve d'absence je
vais y arriver
donc cette phrase elle est doublement
problématique puisqu'elle est elle est
allée fou sur deux aspects alors c'est
parti
c'est parti alors dans la revue science
ah ça y est c'est parti pour les preuves
que la création est vrai le good work de
l'université de californie mentionne la
sérieuse déception des évolutionnistes
alors on va commencer déjà par recherché
qui est ce monsieur ds ou droff qui
publie dans science woodroffe signs one
hits r'n'b l'intérieur c'est quand même
assez ou fin quand même s'il est
vraiment si connu que ça ce monsieur
woodroffe
on devrait quand même trouvé sa page un
peu plus facilement un voile assez
woodruff effectivement dans ce cas là où
droit free search mc
donc oui en plus ils voudraient
peut-être pour ça aussi qu'on trouve à
rien c'est parce que la mal orthographié
cochon
retournons sur google scholar avec good
rohff du coup keane sélection sociale
jeune structure a déjà apparemment on
est quand même sur quelqu'un qui a
travaillé sur les chimpanzés qui fait de
l'omi nos idées effectivement donc à bon
on est quand même voilà et science un
article de woodruff
de futures évolutions effectivement c
est effectivement quelqu'un qui a publié
dans science
mais il s'appelle woodruff annoncé dans
pnns bon punaise ça reste une bonne ça
reste de la bonne revue donc on est
quand même face déjà on n'est pas en
train de détourner les propos d'un
scientifique qui n'existerait pas bah
donc c'est woods
réf pas woods rohff voilà ça
effectivement c'est beaucoup plus dur de
faire du fact checking quand on écrit
mal les noms des gens sains
encore une fois toujours pas de
guillemets pour la citation mais les
espèces fossiles restent inchangées
durant pratiquement toute leur histoire
et leurs archives ne fournissent pas le
moindre exemple d'une transition
significative web 1 donc maintenant il
faut chercher l'origine de cette
citation là parce que ça ça sent la
citation qui est complètement sortie de
son contexte
ça sent le truc qui est complètement
sortie de son contexte mais je suis sûr
qu'il n'est pas le premier à le sortir
de son contexte parce que s'il ya bien
un truc qu'on peut s'attendre à propos
des créationnistes c'est qu'il manque
d'imagination et qu'il repompe les idées
chez d'autres gens
owni donc si je google créationnisme et
woodruff donc là on a pill gators la
théorie de la création
donc là il faut chercher ou d' art of
hand fossiles louis corde
ah bah voilà voilà c'est comme ça qu'on
fait une citation ma gueule quand même
donc on de fo sur le boycott professeur
boudoir university californie rights
watch au sol speeches women and shine
through doubt most of the history and
sorcery cordes fails to contain ce
single example of signification signifie
qu'une transition oil
donc là on a la citation anglaise de
base on va pouvoir commencer à
travailler sérieusement
donc évidemment
tombe sur cette route là où jean chine
c'est en quoi ces deux fossiles 'record'
sayan ce volume 208
peut-être qu'on va directement allé sur
sayan ce magazine times magazine
le voilà ce magazine
maintenant les archives les archives
c'est dans les archives que je veux
aller directement c'est pas la peine de
m'envoyer on veut un numéro qui date de
1981 je sais même pas ils vont avoir ça
1981 oui 1980 c'est le volume 208 le
volume 208 de 1980
page que volume 208 208 208 3 207 jetez
rien n'a beaucoup de 208 en plus sur la
pac à 208 alors
la page c'est 716 alors ce sera
peut-être pas le premier si on imagine
que ces rangées relativement
correctement ce sera peut-être lassé
page 6 ça s'arrête à la page s'arrête à
la page 76 avril documation doit aller à
la pêche 700 et 10 pages et qui à 70
pages par volume faut aller jusqu'au
volume
enfin ce jusqu'au 10e 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
et 10 c'est peut-être celui là j'aurais
pas dû faire ça
non on est allé trop loin ça commence à
1000 celui là
voyez comme c'est compliqué le fact
checking vous voyez que c'est compliqué
1 2 c'est facile de balancer une
connerie c'est beaucoup plus facile de
la dalle est voir d'où elle sort
[Rires]
voyez comme c'est comme ces casses pieds
vous le sentez là ça que j'aime bien
avec les démones kg pénitence c'est que
là vous le sentez à quel point ces
casses pieds d'aller vérifier tout tout
ce que les gens disent donc 716 le voile
à 716
woodruff donc je veux le pdf le pdf
évidemment qu'il va pas être gratos le
pdf tu as y voyons il est gratos donc
évolution biologique
enfin évolution une vue par biologique
hanoi a qu'un exemple c'est que la samp
helpage est-ce qu'on va réussir à la
voir
[Musique]
ou pas ou pas ainsi il est gratos il est
gratos
yeah yeah donc l'évolution
de paléo biological view par david s
wood réf et non pas houde rohff et on va
essayer de trouver cette fameuse
citation donc unchanged 3 août
trouve pas le mot un châssis voilà donc
darwin et le et la plupart des
subséquentes otor donc des auteurs
d'après inclus gg simpson ont soutenus
que la plupart des transitions évolutive
ont lieu à l'intérieur de ligne est
établie par gradualisme fils éthiques
guidés par la sédation la sélection
naturelle
mais les fossiles restent inchangées
durant la plupart de leur histoire et
leur registre fossile ne montre pas un
seul exemple de transition signifie
quand
de même il est difficile il est
difficile de de justifier une
accélération du taux d'évolution durant
ces périodes de radiation adaptative un
modèle alternatif d'évolution celui des
équilibres ponctué introduit par nils
goods nils eldridge et stephen jay gould
dans les années 70 morts fully à quand
donc rend plus facilement content d'eux
mêmes observations à 6 d'après cette
découverte majeure l'évolution rapide
est typiquement associés à des
événements de spéciation qui au cur de
façon critique dans deux îles dans des
populations isolées souvent à la limite
géographique des de la distribution de
ces espèces voilà taden donc c'était
bien une grosse phrase dégueulasse
sortie de son contexte ce que monsieur
woodruff voulais dire c'est que on ne
voit pas on ne voit souvent pas
d'évolution on observe des périodes de
stase dans le registre fossile et du
coup ça soutient plus le modèle des
équilibres ponctuée de stephen jay gould
modèle évolutif qui sous-entend qui qui
dans lequel pour stephen jay gould et
niels eldredge les espèces restent en
stase pendant une longue période
évoluent très rapidement reste en stase
de nouveau et évolué pendant de longues
périodes
ce qui d'ailleurs explique pourquoi on
observe plus souvent des stages dans le
registre évolue dans le registre fossile
stase dont nous parle monsieur woodruff
que dès que de l'évolution graduelle
donc cette phrase n'est pas là pour
contredire l'évolution monsieur
l'évolution n'est pas scientifique cette
phrase elle est là pour contredire le
gradualisme fils éthiques
le gradualisme qui est si tu es là le
c'est une phrase qui a été sortie de son
contexte par des créationnistes
américain et qui a été copié collé avec
une faute dans le nom du bus dans le nom
de son auteur par un créationniste
français médiocre
et voilà est là vous avez quand même un
mec qui vous dit l'évolution n'est pas
scientifique alors que lui même est
incapable de faire les recherches pour
vérifier que les conneries qu'ils y sont
vrais ou faux ce sont des manipulations
ou pas d'ailleurs parce qu'à ce niveau
là c'est même plus du vrai et du faux
c'est de la manipulation prendre une
phrase et la sortir de son contexte
c'est pas un mensonge c'est de la
manipulation
voilà va te faire enfumer
va te faire en caux.les chez les tubes
de chez les tubes de colle grecque
voilà quoi
cette personne est soit d'une
incompétence flagrante soit un menteur
et haut et on t'aimait en tout cas quoi
qu'il arrive j'ai du mal à croire qu'on
puisse accorder à ces propos la moindre
valeur
mais bon comme je le disais c'est
certainement un truc qu'elle a piqué un
autre créationnistes donc de base c'est
créationnistes étaient eux mêmes des
menteurs alors voila c c'est du mensonge
c'est du mensonge par procuration dans
les strates où ils mènent leur chasse
aux faux cils de format intermédiaire
donc formes intermédiaires
apparemment on a l'air de nous autres
évolutionniste on a l'air d'être au
courant qui a pas de formes
intermédiaires mais apparemment les
cherche
d'après lui ce serait quand même débile
je veux dire si on était au courant qui
a pas de formes intermédiaires et qu on
les invente est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
irait les chercher
pourquoi est-ce qu'on irait à la chasse
aux fossiles qui n'existe pas je veux
dire t'es con ou quoi
pourquoi tu dis des choses comme ça on
est à la limite de la contradiction dans
les strates où ils mènent leur chasse
aux formes d'intermédiaires les
darwinistes trouve constamment des
fossiles d'êtres vivants n'ayant pas
subi le moindre changement au cours des
millions d'années et donc n'ayant pas
été soumis à un processus d'évolution et
c'est pour ça que on a nommé des
centaines de milliers d'espèces fossiles
c'est parce qu'elles sont toutes
pareilles
oui madame il ya des centaines de
milliers d'espèces fossiles non on n'a
peut-être pas des centaines de milliers
c'est pour ça qu'on a nommé des milliers
d'espèces fossiles il ya des milliers de
genre de dinosaures par exemple mais
c'est parce qu'ils sont tous pareil
parce qu'ils évoluent pas maintenant
mais si les espèces n'évoluez pas ma
grande ou mon grand je sais pas
qu'est-ce que tu es tu crois qu'ils
auraient des espèces différentes dans le
registre fossile que celle qui a
aujourd'hui je veux dire si l'évolution
n'existe pas les espèces qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui c'est les mêmes que par le
passé donc normalement c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à propos des
trilobites n'y a pas de raison qu'il y
ait des trilobites puisque normalement
par le passé les espèces étaient les
mêmes qu'aujourd'hui
or il ya une prolifération d'espèces
paléontologique
mais il n'y a pas d'évolution donc ya
pas de spéciation pour créer ces espèces
donc c'est de la magie c'est quoi c'est
sais quoi qui crée la diversité bah on
saura pas on saura pas parce que cette
personne est là pour nous vendre pour
nous vendre des questions et pas pour
nous vendre des réponses
c'est un vendeur de questions c'est pire
que les vendeurs de vérité c'est un
vendeur de questions c'est à dire moi je
fais que poser des questions voilà c'est
tout allez voir la vidéo du débat au
coeur des étoiles sur les gens qui font
que poser des questions les preuves du
fait de la création abonde par millions
chaque jour ah mais oui on en revient à
la wii les preuves du fait de la
création les preuves du fait que tout a
été créé par magie je rappelle la
création c'est ça c'est tout a été créé
par magie par la volonté d'un être
surnaturel
je vous le rappelle que c'est un tenant
d'une organisation religieuse donc pour
lui la création c'est ça donc tout a été
créé par magie par un être surnaturel il
qualifie ça de fait déjà bon pourquoi
pas mais mais mais surtout il appelle
des preuves depuis tout à l'heure un
depuis tout à l'heure ça parle de
preuves on les attend encore ses preuves
parce que ça ça c'était pas une preuve
ça ça c'était une déclaration sortie de
son contexte je rappelle les preuves du
fait de la création abonde par millions
chaque jour et je ne vais vous en
montrer aucune
non c'est pas ça qui dit alors que les
fossiles de formes intermédiaires tant
attendue ne sont nulle part un par celle
que je vous ai déjà montré au dessus ça
dont je vous ai déjà parlé
les évolutionnistes ont dû alors se
contenter de soeur de représenter ce qui
en fait constituer une preuve de la
création sous les traits de fossiles de
formes intermédiaires c'est alambiqué
comme forme donc on a pris des fossiles
date de forme un terme et non la prix
des fossiles qui étaient pas des formes
intermédiaires pour les hommes pour les
remettre en forme intermedia alors là ça
sent la pirouette
alors attention c'est de la gymnastique
à ce niveau là ça sent la pirouette qui
va nous parler de faux cils
intermédiaire en nous disant est en fait
c'est une preuve de l'accusation
en fait c'est une preuve que les espèces
évoluent pas archéoptéryx est une preuve
que les espèces n'évolue pas amis
dinosaures mille oiseaux voyez bien que
ça évolue pas c'est tomber ou quoi donc
l'épreuve on les attend toujours mais
j'attends cette liste de preuves
il y en a des millions des preuves de la
création et pourtant on les attend au
moyen de différentes techniques de
propagande donc encore une fois la
propagande que je dis qu'elles
n'existaient pas que j'ai démontré
qu'elle n'existe pas ils tentèrent de
dépeindre des formes de vie hautement
développées et complexes remontant à des
millions d'années comme preuve de leur
propre théorie en remettant sous en
remettant leur interprétation biaisée
des en soumettant leur interprétation
biaisée des fossiles il tentait ainsi de
faire passer le système complexe et
développer d'elle d'oiseaux pour les
ailes en développement et les nageoires
des poissons de pour leur future path
d'une créature se préparant à émerger
sur la terre ferme a donc référence
directe à al archéoptéryx est donc aussi
là quand puisqu'auparavant je vois qu'il
le site juste après ainsi le chercheur a
présenté le coelacanthe comme un exemple
de transition entre l'eau et la terre et
l'archaeopteryx comme un reptile
évoluant du sol vers les airs alors
ouais là où le grandit greyson la
famille greyson vous présente les
acrobates donc regarder le coelacanthe
il possède des nageoires charnue il
possède l'équivalent d'un numérus dans
le bras mais on va dire que non c'est
pas un numerus et on va même dire que
c'est carrément une preuve contre
l'évolution
pardon et regarder l'archaeopteryx il a
des plumes comme un oiseau il a un
squelette de dinosaure mais on va dire
que c'est une preuve contre l'évolution
pardon où il ya un truc que j'ai oublié
aussi dans l'épreuve contre caen dans la
preuve de l'évolution c'est qu'on a des
on retrouve dans le registre fossile des
espèces de sol donc des poissons plats
qui ont l'oeil à moitié migrer ça il
faut que je vous le montre aussi comme
dans le fait que l'évolution c'est un
fait c'est dans notre vidéo sur la
claviste ico justement où justement on
faisait notre petit clin d'oeil à un
groupe et j'ai oublié de mettre un
espace mais c'est pas grave on le trouve
quand même la classification poule et
rock'n'roll donc dedans on parle on
parle de ces fameux poisson plat voilà
donc les poissons plats qui ont les deux
yeux du même côté voyez pas ce qu'ils
sont plats donc ça sert à rien d'avoir
un oeil dans la boue ça sert à rien
d'avoir un oeil dans la gadoue et en
fait il ya un fossile qui s'appelle en
fils tio mais ce faux site dans fister
hommes
il a l'oeil à moitié migrer donc ça
c'est bien les créationnistes qui nous
disent que des fonctions là parce que je
rebondis sur le fait qu'ils nous disent
qu'il ya une moitié de nageoires et une
moitié dell ou un truc comme ça voilà
des en développement voilà donc il nous
dit qu'à que des structures en
développement ça n'existe pas bon bah
voilà
magnifique structure en développement
c'est l'oeil à moitié migré chez en fils
teom
donc si les structures en développement
ça marche très bien ça marche très très
bien pour la classification pied parfait
c'est parfait
et pour les veaux
sion alors vas-y balance nous tombe à
lens nous ta grande acrobaties donc en
réalité même ses restes fossilisés
démontrent que ces créatures étaient
dotés de caractéristiques excessivement
complexes et non intermédiaire lorsqu un
coelacanthe la des êtres vivants objet
des spéculations évolutionniste fut
pêcher dans les eaux profondes de 1938
près de 400 millions d'années après les
spécimens fossilisés tous les rêves tous
les rêves évolutionniste volé en éclats
va absolument pas trouve moi un seul
article qui dit oh mon dieu ils ont
trouvé assez là quand on est foutu tu
n'en trouvera pas au contraire les
évolutionnistes ils ont exulté parce que
c'était la première fois qu'il voyait un
représentant de la famille des
coelacanthe vivant en l'incarnation de
du coelacanthe moderne
donc en fait les évolutionnistes ils
étaient super contents ils étaient
d'autant plus content que quand ils ont
pu disséquer enfin le coelacanthe ils
ont pu constater que le coelacanthe il
avait effectivement des caractères qui
sont intermédiaires entre les entre les
poissons et les tétrapodes et notamment
ils ont pu voir les muscles des
nageoires parce que les coelacanthe
comme tous les poissons à nageoires
charnue sont les seuls à avoir des
muscles dans les nageoires qui sont les
ancêtres de nos murs des muscles de nos
bras et de nos jambes et ils ont pu voir
le joint intracrânien qui est typique
des sarko pts ériger un sarko petit rien
qui inclut les tétrapodes ils ont pu
voir aussi les dents labyrinthe aux
d'onde du coelacanthe ça on l'a
découvert très récemment que les
coelacanthe ont des dents labyrinthe aux
dons exactement comme les amphibiens
qu'on appelle les labyrinthes aux dons
est un donc le coelacanthe a des dents
labyrinthe aux dons comme les amphibiens
qu'on appelle les labyrinthes aux dons
tu ça va ça te parle là ou pas toujours
pas donc non les évolutionnistes au
contraire ils ont sauté au plafond de
joie en apprenant l'existence d'un
coelacanthe moderne parce que ça leur a
permis de voir beaucoup plus de choses
que s'il s'était contenté juste des
coelacanthe fossiles coelacanthe
fossiles qui je donc
à renier a été retrouvé au crétacé donc
pas il ya 400 millions d'années
je sais pas quel à lille à moins de 100
millions d'années je sais plus
exactement lequel mais bref pas 400
millions d'années donc en plus mal
renseigné le monsieur les
évolutionnistes connurent arvert
similaire avec l'archaeopteryx là encore
le coelacanthe ya le côté fossiles
vivants qui permet quand même qui donne
un peu de grain à moudre aux
créationnistes mais alors j'attends de
voir la connerie qui va sortir pour
l'archaeopteryx parce que là je veux
dire qu'est ce qui va nous dire alors il
va certainement nous sortir l'histoire
de ceux de ricciardo went atteint dame
qui a créé et qui a décrit
l'archaeopteryx mais ça sauf que sauf
ricciardo wayne était tellement anti
évolutionniste tellement anti darwiniste
surtout il était vraiment anti
darwiniste plus quand ils évolutionniste
il était un peu intelligente design
plutôt que ricciardo wen enfin on
appellerait ça dure et de l'intelligent
design aujourd'hui ça n'existait pas
encore le terme intelligent de design
n'existait pas à l'époque mais bref il
était surtout anti darwiniste ricciardo
wayne donc il n'a tellement pas voulu
voir en archéoptéryx le dinosaure qu'il
est parce que je voulais montrer tout à
l'heure je le dire il ya des griffes il
ya des dents
le squelette est celui d'un dinosaure de
a à z c'est celui d'un petit dinosaure
d'ailleurs huxley juste après a fait
remarquer à owen dès qu'ils ont dans les
mêmes dépôts que là où on avait trouvé
archéoptéryx ont trouvé comme sonia tu
ce qui est quasiment identique en tout
point à part qu'il a des plus petits
bras comme sonia tus parce que c'est pas
à manier rapt rien mais je veux dire
comme sonia tus il a en tous points
identiques quasiment archéoptéryx part
qu'il a des plus petits bras et qu'il
n'y a pas de plumes préserver sur
console natus probablement à cause de
verdun plus d'un d'un phénomène d'un
billet de fossilisation que d'un réel
phénomène que confessions ait us
n'avaient pas de plumes consomme hiatus
avec très probablement quelques plumes
quand même peut-être pas aussi jolie car
qu'eric s'appelle pas peut-être pas
aussi développés mais au moins des
plumes filamenteuses et quelques plumes
bien développée par ci par là mais bref
je m'égare
donc oxley a fait remarquer à
ricciardone que quand même il avait
sérieusement fait de la merde avec son
archéoptéryx en disant que c'était pas
un dinosaure parce que je veux dire
ricciardo one c'est quand même le mec
qui a inventé le mot dinosaures ils
regardent archéoptéryx et il ne veut pas
y voir un dinosaure et donc il l'a
décrit comme un oiseau et pas comme un
dinosaure
donc je veux dire là c'est plus un
exemple d' aveuglement mais total et
dogmatique pour le coup plus qu'un
exemple anti évolutionniste le coup de
l'archaeopteryx mais on va voir si c'est
vraiment ça qui parle parce que là je
lui fais peut-être un faux procès
peut-être qu'il n'a pas cette culture là
peut-être qu'il est encore moins
cultivés que ça qui va inventer un truc
complètement con donc avec
l'archaeopteryx on a connu un revers
similaires parce que la science
considère désormais comme un oiseau à
part entière j'en ai [ __ ] j'en ai
marre d'avoir raison les évolutionnistes
prédire tous perdirent tous les
arguments quand archéoptéryx dépeint
pendant des années comme une preuve
cruciale de la transition imaginaire de
la terre à l'air s'avéra posséder des
muscles de vol parfait
dd
des muscles des muscles puisque le sur
archéoptéryx mais tu as fumé
me 10,9 archéoptéryx en plus juste à
l'heure je les écris bien des muscles
sur le caillou là parce que s'est il
alors on peut on peut sortir le spécimen
de londres quand même qui était celui
qui avait ricciardo wayne à l'époque
parce que là il nous parle de la
découverte d'archaeopteryx donc c'est le
spécimen de berlin qu'on a déjà vu mais
là du coup je vais vous montrer le
spécimen de londres qu'on n'a pas encore
vu et tu vas me dire si sur le spécimen
de londres que ricciardo wen avait sous
les yeux
voilà ça c'est le spécimen je pense que
ces spécimens original peut-être pas
avec la permission du natural history
museum donc oui c'est une photo du
spécimen original celui là et tu vas me
dire où tu vois des muscles tet2 non
mais franchement des muscles willard et
muscle tout à fait il avait des muscles
de vol parfait alors en plus maintenant
on va on va faire un petit peu
d'anatomie parce que quand même ça me
semble important mais archéoptéryx bird
et comme ce hiatus
enfin je vais essayer de vous trouver
cette image qui est très connu
voilà qui comparent l'archaeopteryx un
oiseau et comme sonia tus donc voila
comme sonia tu sais comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est exactement ou
presque le même squelette archéoptéryx à
quelques détails près sauf que il a des
petits bras mais vous voyez là des
castes rallye il a des griffes
ils ont des dents voilà la longue que
les griffes sur les pâtes les os des
pattes pas complètement fusionné tout ça
c'est pareil et tout ça ça n'est pas
présent chez les oiseaux vous voyez la
queue courte ya pas de griffes les
doigts sont séparés enfin les doigts
sont tous fusionner chez les oiseaux et
évidemment il ya un becquet pas dedans
là il y avait pas de bec maintenant
maintenant loti nous dit des muscles os
a parfaitement adaptés aux vols faut
quand même avoir une profonde
fainéantise pour pas aller vérifier ça
pour affirmer ça sent le vérifier parce
que c'est quand même facile à vérifier
regarder les eaux du vol ils sont
accrochés là sur ce qu'on appelle
balleux sur ce qu'on appelle le sternum
donc le sternum qui d'ailleurs remplace
legast rallye qui sont présentes chez
archéoptéryx et combien hiatus donc ça
c'est avoir des dégâts stralis et les
côtes ventrale c'est un caractère
profondément reptilien pour le coup ça
fait très très reptiles d'avoir des gars
stralis les oiseaux n'ont pas à la place
ils ont un grand sternum gigantesque sur
lequel sont attachées les eaux en
fallait muscles qu'on appelle le blanc
chez les poulets parce que c'est les
énormes muscles pectoraux qui servent à
battre des ailes
vous voyez la taille de l'os
là vous voyez la taille du machin ça
c'est un à ce qui est gigantesque pour
fournir une attache à des muscles du vol
qui sont gigantesques archéoptéryx il a
zéro sternum
il a zéro sternum enfin il a peut-être
un petit sternum la figure et pas très
clair tatin sternum qui était
cartilagineux mais il était tout petit
quoi qu'il arrive il n'est pas il n'est
pas là puisque ans et en plus on l'a on
pourrait me sortir oui mais c'est pas
parce qu'on l'a pas c'est pas parce
qu'il est pas préservée qu'il n'était
pas présent quand l'animal était vivant
si cissé il n'est pas là puisqu'il ya
des gars se rallie à la place à la place
du sternum il ya un autre os dont il n'y
a pas la place de mettre un sternum
donc là on est à sur chez archéoptéryx
qui avait pas de sternum donc on est sûr
que les muscles pectoraux était tout
petit donc on est sûr qu'il avait pas
des muscles adaptés aux vols
tout au plus il planait archéoptéryx
avec ses petites ailes mais il volait
pas haut comme un oiseau donc vous êtes
sont donc la posséder des muscles de vol
parfait mais va te faire [ __ ]
c'est une insulte là c'est une insulte
de la compétence pareil de la
feignantise ne pas vérifier des infos
qui sont accessibles en 2 clics
je veux dire tout à l'heure la citation
j'ai mis trois plombes à la trouver à la
limite
disons qu'avant de salir la mémoire de
quelqu'un enfin avant de salir le
travail de quelqu'un ce serait bien
quand même que tu te renseignes mail à
dire que sa poussette pas de muscles
nombre tagen que ça possède des muscles
de vol parfait mais ta gueule quoi
et des plumes idéalement adéquate au vol
c'est vrai c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu
archéoptéryx est imparfait
d'intermédiaire entre oiseaux et
dinosaures c'est parce qu'il a des
plumes qui font très très bon réseau et
un squelette qui font très très
dinosaures une parfaite structure d'elle
avec un parfait squelettes de dinosaures
donc l'archaeopteryx va te faire [ __ ]
je veux dire c'est pas une preuve que
l'évolution n'existe pas je veux dire
quand bien même quand bien même vous
partiriez du principe qu archéoptéryx
est un oiseau donc que ce squelette là
c'est juste un oiseau et tout c'est tout
voilà on va oublier le fait qu'ils
ressemblent à un dinosaure me dire vous
trouvez vraiment car keynote rx c'est
vous trouvez vraiment qu'on passe
d'archaeopteryx à un oiseau moderne sans
aucune évolution là tous ses doigts
plein griffe là cette longue que sega
strady derrière et l'absence de bec et
la présence de dents il ya rien qui vous
choque
le dire il n'y a rien qui vous fait vous
dira oui mais entre archéoptéryx et
l'oiseau et les oiseaux modernes ya eu
de l'évolution il ya forcément eu de
l'évolution entre les deux même en
partant du principe qu archéoptéryx il
fait pas le pont entre les dinosaures et
les oiseaux
tu pars pas d'archaeopteryx en disant
ben oui c'est déjà la noise au tout va
bien tout va bien il n'y a rien qui a
changé entre une poule et un
archéoptéryx voix il ya deux trois
griffes en moins il ya une vingtaine de
dents - il ya un bec en plus y'a bon ben
voilà non mais c'est pas de l'évolution
ça c'est des changements c'est pas de
l'évolution c'est des changements mais
vous êtes plein de merde mais vous êtes
plein de merde
en fait vous n'avez aucune aucun sens de
la logique élémentaire
d'autres incidents ont remis en question
ouvertement le concept de formes
intermédiaires comme celui de l'homme de
piltdown
le concept de l'homme de piles d'armes
alors petit rappel l'homme de piltdown
cette info on le sait depuis 1950
il a été découvert en minaudant début
des années 1900 donc on a mis 50 ans à
se rendre compte que l'homme de piles
john était un faux et honte et c'est
vrai à l'époque ça a bien fait chier les
évolutionnistes
maintenant quand il ya un fou qui sort
comme par exemple au cul nu dans ta vie
ce pour prendre un exemple très très
très récent au plus dans ta vi a été a
été interprétée par certains
paléontologues un peu on suspecte que ça
a été un peu au forcing comme étant un
oiseau avec des caractères très très
reptilien donc là pour le coup ce serait
un chaînon manquant mal interprété enfin
on va on va essayer de se contorsionner
à sa vision créationnistes donc on va
dire ouais aucune vente avis en fait
c'était un lézard mais ils ont préféré
l'interpréter comme un coma noises aux
intermédiaires entre les dinosaures et
les oiseaux
vous voyez ils vous mentent ouais sauf
que là sauf que la supercherie à la cie
supercherie il ya parce que encore une
fois c'est un gros procès d'intention de
dire que l'interprétation était forcée
comme ça les auteurs s'en sont défendus
mais bref
en admettant qu'on vit dans le petit
monde des complots de l'évolution n'est
pas scientifique là on va dire que
c'était une supercherie la supercherie
elle a duré deux semaines
deux semaines après il y avait un
article qui sortait disant non au cumul
dans ta vie c'est un lézard point bas et
ça a été fait par des scientifiques et
encore et encore récemment il ya eu
trois ou quatre nouveaux articles qui
sont sortis commentant la sphère docu
lieu dante avis et tous écrits par des
paléontologues tous écrits par des
voleuses évolutionniste darwiniste ils
étaient où les créationnistes sur reclus
dans ta vie ben moi je vais te le dire
il était encore en pls à essayer de
comprendre pourquoi la bible dit pas
qu'il ya au cul dans ta vie dans la
bible voilà où ils étaient les
créationnistes ou dans le camp là ça
marche pareil donc ou dans n'importe
quoi la torah dans le témoin de jéhovah
j'en sais rien des conneries qu'il dit
c'est jeudi
voilà l'homme de piltdown c'est ouais
yahia au début du siècle on mettait 50
ans avant de se rendre compte qu'on
faisait une connerie maintenant on met
quinze jours il faudrait peut-être se
tenir à la page l'archéo raptor ça a été
pareil ça a tenu un an
ça a tenu un an avant qu'on se rendre
compte que le fossile n'était pas un
vrai faux cils donc et larqué orateur
c'était en 2005 je crois qu'il me
rappelle bien donc les fossiles quand
ils se font maintenant s'en rend compte
très vite
à l'époque on s'en rendait pas compte
très vite donc effectivement pendant 50
ans il ya l'homme de piltdown qu'à
traîner dans la littérature et on était
dans un contexte de d'angleterre
dominant dominé le monde politiquement
l'homme de piltdown était payant
politiquement et du coup
scientifiquement aussi du coup le comme
maintenant les états unis dominent
politiquement et scientifiquement le le
monde de la recherche
donc voilà à l'époque un anglais un
chercheur anglais qui te dit l'homme de
piltdown c'est la parole c'est la parole
qu'il faut suivre évidemment aller on
les écoutait plus que on hésite et plus
on les écoutait plus que tous les autres
chercheurs qui à l'époque on dit mais
non l'homme de piltdown c'est des
conneries parce qu'il ya des chercheurs
à l'époque qui ont dit que l'homme de
piltdown c'est des conneries
1 tous les d'ailleurs à la fin
d'ailleurs il ya surtout c'est surtout
les chercheurs anglais qui défendent et
de l'homme de piltdown les chercheurs de
continentaux les français les allemands
que sais-je
ils étaient plutôt sceptiques quant à
l'homme de piltdown mais évidemment il
ne faisait pas autorités comme les
chercheurs anglais donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça un d'affaires de
l'homme de piltdown donc oui j'admets
que à l'époque l'homme de piltdown avait
bien arrangé la vision de l'évolution de
l'homme qui avait certaines personnes
mais ça n'arriverait plus aujourd'hui ça
n'arriverait plus aujourd'hui d'une et
de fait on a laissé tomber aujourd'hui
l'homme de piltdown ces banques je veux
dire le la le registre fossile de
l'évolution humaine maintenant il
contient des milliers de fossiles et
pour l'instant on n'a pas trop de
raisons de croire que qu'ils sont tous
des hommes de piltdown il ya des
milliers de fossiles et ils sont tous
bien préservés accessible par la plupart
des paléoanthropologues sous réserve de
montrer patte blanche évidemment c'est
pas le premier guide créationnistes à
qui on donnera l'accès à lui si
évidemment c'est même tellement
d'ailleurs là la palais on la
paléontologie et particulièrement la
paléoanthropologie est en train de
tellement nettoyer sa façon de faire qui
a même des gens qui ont osé dire que
dans l'ue s'il y avait eu une vertèbre
qui appartenait peut-être à un babouin
donc on en est même à dire vous voyez
que on est même capable de remettre en
question des monuments tels que l'uci
donc voilà mais l'uci c'est pas le seul
australopithèques qu'on y est on a en a
un autre à l'hôpital que sediba où il ya
deux squelettes quasiment complet on a
un australopithecus prometheus où ils
little foot qui est le squelette
d'australopithèque le plus complet au
monde
on a plein d'autres squelettes qui sont
complètes australopithèques donc même si
lui si on considère que c'est plus un
squelette pour lequel on peut se fier
bat lucie de toute façon il est 40%
complet comparé à australopithecus
prometheus quand on connaît 95% du
squelette
voilà à quoi on peut on peut s'en passer
la théorie de l'évolution ira toujours
très très bien avec ou sans hommes de
piltdown avec ou sans lui si c'est pas
parce que tu retires un fossile du mix
parce que tu crois qu'il est faux que ça
que ça change grand chose
bref et puis j'ai aussi fait une vidéo
quand sur l'homme de piltdown donc vous
pouvez aller voir en tracts aux sciences
sommes deux pilotes j'ai fait une vidéo
dessus qui récapitule la sphère le très
rapidement parce que c'est une affaire
qui m'énerve beaucoup j'aime pas en
parler longtemps comme celui de l'homme
de piltdown est celle de l'homme du
nebraska j'ai jamais entendu parler de
l'homme du nebraska j'imagine que c'est
encore un faux et nt1 nebraska men
nebraska men allez c'est parti
fait moins bien fais moi rêver montre
moi l'homme du nebraska montre moi
comment qu'il était
nebraska man wikipedia en scène sur
wikipédia je suis arrivé à un niveau
espéré au pit et que je mets un grand
singe sur la base de quelques dents
voilà oui bah il ya quelqu'un qui a fait
une grosse théorie sur quelques dents à
l'époque on n'avait pas grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent surtout en 1922 on
n'avait vraiment pas grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent parce qu'on n'avait
pas encore découvert australopithecus à
l'époque donc le premier vrai beau crâne
dan hominidés anciens australopithecus
il a été découvert qu'en 1924 et publié
en 1925 donc à l'époque on n'avait même
pas encore australopithecus donc oui je
peux comprendre que quelqu'un qui trouve
une paire dedans en amérique du nord et
commencé à faire une grande théorie qui
s'est avérée fausse plus tard aucun
problème j'ai même pas envie de regarder
plus que ça c'est des conneries à
désespérer par l'absence totale de
formes intermédiaires les
évolutionnistes allèrent jusqu'à fixer
une mâchoire d'orangs outans un crâne
d'hommes récemment décédé moyen-âge
quand même il le nommèrent l'homme de
piltdown est exhibée à la fabrication
pendant près de 40 ans ce fossile
fabrique est exposée au british museum
für rapidement retirée des vitrines
lorsque la supercherie fut mise à jour
fut mise à jour par le
paléoanthropologue legros clark et pas
par des créationnistes d'ailleurs donc
la paléoanthropologie est une science
qui s'auto corrige est pas une science
qui se complaît dans sa bêtise
contrairement à toi et à tes copains
créationnistes d'une et de deux
non on a enfin l'homme de piltdown avait
peut-être été faites toutes pièces mais
comme je les dis maintenant on a un
registre fossile d'une bonne vingtaine
d'espèces et de plusieurs milliers de
fossiles
donc ce serait quand même bien la misère
si tous étaient complètement faux et on
sait que tous ne sont pas complètement
faux et même moi j'ai pu en verve en
voir certains moi même et en toucher
certains moi même pour voir qu'il
n'était pas faux
donc route voilà zut il faut quand même
enfin je veux dire oui à l'est et puis
en plus oui il faut se remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque oui désespéré par
l'absence de formes intermédiaires les
évolutionnistes ont créé l'homme de
piltdown oui en 1905 je crois en l'homme
de piltdown regardant au début des
années 1900 quoi et l'appareil du
nebraska c'est 1922 on vient de le voir
donc oui en dans l'eau début des années
1900 ouais on était un peu short en
fossiles ça j'avoue donc on avait un peu
tendance à vouloir voir des chaînons
manquants dans tout ce qu'on trouvait ça
a changé maintenant quand même
et comme je les dis maintenant ça a
tellement changé que les faut on les
repère en moins de deux semaines
donc dès que quelqu'un essaye de faire
des grandes théories sur des fossiles
qui n'ont pas l'air tout à fait net ça
se voit tout de suite et c'est tout de
suite repéré l'homme du nebraska fut le
sujet de nombreuses illustrations et
reconstructions imaginaires
donc là bas d'ailleurs l'homme du
nebraska je vous disais j'en ai jamais
entendu parler et c'est là justement
qu'on voit que le mec qui copie colle en
faille traduit et copie colle des trucs
de créationnistes anglais pain anglais
américains ce que ça à part les
américains qui connaît l'homme du
l'histoire de l'homme du nebraska quoi
le dire voilà donc ça c'est copier
coller d'un truc créationnistes
américain au cas où vous vous en doutiez
pas après la citation tronquée de tout à
l'heure je veux dire c'est c'est la
preuve que le mec il réfléchit même pas
par lui-même quoi c'est déplorable
déplorable pathétique critique l'homme
du nebraska fut le sujet de nombreuses
illustrations de reconstitution
imaginaire bas mais en même temps il ya
que des dents alors le reste faut bien
d'imaginer toutes basées sur une simple
dante
s'inspirant de cette dans les
évolutionnistes ce imaginaire qu'elle
appartenait à un fossile de formes
intermédiaires combinant des traits
humains et simiesque mais il s'avéra
plus tard que cette dent appartenait un
ours sauvage oui bah ça c'est arrivé ça
je veux bien croire que c'est arrivé
quand début des années 1900 à l'ours
saadé dans des dents d'omnivore donc
comme les dents de cochon c'est arrivé
plein de fois dans l'histoire qu'on ait
confondu des temps de dour ces deux
cochons avec des dents humaines ans
après il a fait l'objet de
reconstitution bah oui parce qu'il ya
bien fallu quand même dire illustré
finalement à quoi pouvait ressembler cet
humain hypothétique
donc oui on l'a reconstitués comme étant
un humain comme la dent été très grosse
parce que c'était une bande oursons à
supposer que c'était un humain anciens
parce que il ya une tendance à la
réduction de la taille des dents chez
les humains donc c'était le mieux qu'on
pouvait interpréter à l'époque bon donc
je peux comprendre oui la limite je veux
bien croire que cette histoire est vraie
je ne peux aller vérifier parce que ça
me gave c'est pourquoi on peut dire que
les fossiles observé par les nombreux
visiteurs des musées est présenté comme
preuve de l'évolution sont le produit
d'une telle logique frauduleuses non non
tu cite deux exemples qui date d'il ya
cent ans
cent vingt ans maintenant presque pour
l'homme de piltdown tu cite des exemples
qui date de plus il ya plus de 100 ans
en quoi le leader tu discutes quel est
le rapport
quel est le rapport
aucun rapport je veux dire les
paléontologues qui ont fait ça ils sont
morts depuis longtemps leurs étudiants
sont morts depuis longtemps
tu peut pas traiter et au passage ils
nous traitent tous tous les
paléontologues ils nous traitent de
menteur et de fraudeurs en plus même pas
ils utilisent frauduleux quoi donc ils
nous traitent ou les paléontologues de
fraudeurs je dire s'il savait juste mais
la quantité de de concurrence qui lie à
entre les paléoanthropologues
particulièrement parce que c'est quand
même un milieu comme je disais où il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'argent il n'y a pas
beaucoup de faux cils et enfin s'il n'y
a pas beaucoup de faux cils par rapport
au nombre de chercheurs qui a pas ce que
je disais il ya des milliers de fossiles
oui mais il ya des centaines de
chercheurs
donc ça fait pas beaucoup de faux cils
chacun le dire donc oui c'est un milieu
où il ya des normes d'énormes pressions
les uns il se met la pression les uns
sur les autres pour pour que ça ça
marche cette théorie à la con las de la
logique frauduleuse tout ça là pour que
cette théorie du complot là elle marche
faudrait que tous les
paléoanthropologues soient d'accord
entre eux et ils ne sont pas [ __ ] s'il
ya bien un milieu de la recherche
paléontologique où les gens sont pas
d'accord entre eux c'est la
paléoanthropologie quoi je veux dire
s'il y en a un qui fait le moindre faux
pas le voisin d'à côté le repère tout de
suite et le balance mais sans vergogne
sa ce qui s'est produit un peu avec le
cas du fémur de toumaï enfin le fémur de
toumaï qui n'est pas vraiment le fémur
de toumaï c'est juste un fémur deux
primates qui aurait été retrouvé avec le
crâne de toumaï le dira ce truc là il
soit disant ils seraient restés cachés
mais non il n'est pas resté caché
puisque il ya un marc machiavelli robert
thomas chiarelli qui a tout balancé sur
internet et avant lui il ya déjà eu
d'autres paléoanthropologue qui avait
déjà tout balancer sur internet sauf que
ma carélie lui l'a balancé ça dans la
nature donc fatalement il a eu un peu
plus de réponses mais voilà le jeudi at
il ya les cachotteries ça ne marche plus
ça ça a marché parce que c'était le
début du siècle dernier qu'on aimait les
cachotteries aujourd'hui c'est ce que je
veux dire ça ne marche plus il ya trop
de concurrence et on a trouvé on a des
techniques aujourd'hui qui marche trop
bien pour repérer les fraudeurs
donc non non cite moi au moins un
exemple de fraude récente saillie au
moins essayer au moins de faire un
effort que ouais il ya cent ans les
paléontologues c'était dément terre
alors aujourd'hui déjà c'est pas des
menteurs parce que pour le coup l'homme
de piltdown est l'homme du nebraska
c'est des erreurs c'est pas des c'est
pas des mensonges
l'homme du nebraska ça a été interprété
comme étant un homme alors que c'était
une bonne course parce que les dents des
ours et des hommes se ressemblent
beaucoup en effet et l'homme de piltdown
ces infos qui a probablement été créé
par un archéologue amateur et qui a dupé
les paléoanthropologues qui ne se
doutaient de rien donc voilà et qui n'a
pas duper tout le monde d'ailleurs
l'homme de piles tente pour le coup est
l'homme du nebraska c'est quasiment
certain qu'il a pas duper tout le monde
puisque on a fini par s'en rendre compte
une fois de plus donc prout prout
cacahuètes au maintenant il va salir
georges bédard simpson [ __ ] non mais
là il prend des autorités de plus en
plus gros squad georges gaylord simpson
coincer un c'est un des plus grands
paléontologues des vertébrés qui ait
jamais existé quand est-ce qu'il va
s'arrêter
et encore une fois il cite un américain
ce qui prouve bien que ce qui prouve
bien que c'est du copié collé d'un truc
américain le paléontologue
évolutionniste georges gorse hinson du
musée d'histoire du musée américain
d'histoire naturelle reconnaît le
problème des formes intermédiaires au
caire sont confrontés les
évolutionnistes
cela est vrai pour tous les 32e ordre de
mammifères les membres les plus anciens
les plus primitifs donc alors
je vais juste m'arrêter là mais si
l'évolution n'existe pas il n'y a pas de
membre les si les espèces si les espèces
n'évolue pas les membres les plus
anciens ne peuvent pas être les plus
primitifs
ce morceau de phrase déjà ne colle pas
avec une logique créationnistes
déjà rien que le fait de dire les
membres les plus anciens et les plus
primitifs
c'est ça contredit la thèse
créationnistes ça contredit le fixisme
ça veut dire que plus on va donc vers le
passé et plus les espèces ont des
caractères primitif donc déjà là encore
une fois il ya une a compris il n'y a
même pas une incompréhension profonde
c'est juste il ya une une même pas une
volonté de chercher à comprendre les
conneries qu'il copie colle tu vois ce
que je veux dire là bref les membres les
plus anciens les plus primitives de
chaque ordre ont déjà les caractères
ordinaux basique et hop et en aucun cas
il n'est question d'une séquence
approximative continue entre un ordre et
un autre
ce que cette fois je veux dire c'est
qu'en fait c'est une tautologie en fait
cette phrase c'est effectivement je
reconnais je me rappelle plus où il l'a
dit mais je reconnais une citation de
georges bédard simpson c'est une
tautologie en fait cette phrase c'est à
dire que les membres les plus anciens et
les plus primitifs des ordres ont déjà
les caractères des ordres c'est une
tautologie parce que oui sinon les
aurais pas identifiés comme des membres
de ses ordres tu vois ce que je veux
dire c'est par exemple si on prend
l'ordre des arts sio d'actes il les a
reçus au tactile c'est les les antilopes
les vaches les moutons tout ça ils ont
une articulation de la cheville qui a
deux qui a une double articulation au
lieu d'une seule donc la cheville
s'articule en deux points
elle s'articule avec la jambe et avec le
pied au lieu de s'articuler uniquement
avec la jambe donc il ya deux il ya une
double poulies ce qu'on appelle une
double poulies au niveau de
l'articulation de la cheville et on est
capable de dire que des espèces qui
vivait il ya 50 millions d'années
appartiennent aux ars you dactyle y
compris des cétacés
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas qui c'est us
c'est un cétacé avec une astra gala
double poulies avec une avec une
articulation de darciaux dactyle donc on
n'est qu'à donc à mais j'en viendrais
j'y reviendrai juste après donc on est
capable de dire que des espèces qui
vivait il ya 50 millions d'années
appartenait aux assure dactyle
précisément parce qu'elle l'a ce
caractère là donc c'est exactement ce
qu'il dit là les membres les plus
anciens et les plus primitifs ont déjà
les caractères des ordres qui permettent
de les identifier à ses ordres
ben oui c'est normal puisqu'on les a
identifiés à ses ordres par contre ça
veut pas dire que les dents sont pas
différentes ça veut pas dire que le
crâne est pas différent ça veut pas dire
que tout le reste du squelette est pas
différent ça veut juste dire qu'on y
retrouve
l'articulation à double poules y voilà
et en aucun cas il n'est question d'une
séquence à pour le climat tiff constitue
entre un ordre et un autre
donc il n'ya pas de lien en gros de ce
qu'il dit entre un ordre et un autre il
ya des donc les astres les arceaux
d'actes ils sont bien séparées des
périseaux dactyle ils sont bien séparées
des cétacés oui mais ça c'était vrai à
l'époque de georges gaylord simpson dans
les années 50 mais aujourd'hui par
exemple on sait que l'ordre des cétacés
et que l'ordre des architectes ils sont
liés ils sont liés parce qu'on a des
cétacés terrestre comme pas qui s'est
tue ces ados issus qui ont une astragale
à double polycom les a reçus au tactile
ce qui montre que les deux ordres ont un
ancêtre en commun fuck you
donc en plus tu ne cites
et c'est le problème de citer des
références comme georges gaylord simpson
qui sont un peu datés c'est qu'ils ont
dit des choses qui était vrai à l'époque
mais qui le sont plus aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas quand s'arrête la citation
d'ailleurs au passage
donc je sais pas si le reste la de ce
qui vient et c'est aussi censé être du
george diller simpson dans la plupart
des cas les rues la rupture et si nette
et le fossé si large que l'origine de
l'ordre est spéculative est matière à
controverse
c'était vrai dans les années 50 confère
le cas des cétacés
cette absence régulière des formes
transitionnelle ne confine pas aux
mammifères
bah oui la complète avoir un registre
fossile à complet ça s'applique pas que
aux mammifères ceci dit pour les
invertébrés général monde quand même un
registre fossile beaucoup plus complet
et pour les rongeurs aussi par exemple
mais il s'agit d'un phénomène quasi
universelle comme le savent depuis
longtemps les paléontologues
cela est vrai pour presque toutes les
classes d'animaux vertébrés et
invertébrés
cela est vrai pour les classes et pour
les principaux fila d'animaux et c'est
apparemment vrai également pour des
catégories analogue des plantes
donc bon oui le registre fossile et
parcellaire ça c'est ça c'est pas
nouveau en dépit de l'absence totale de
preuves que je n'arrête pas de fournir
depuis tout à l'heure et de façon très
facile les évolutionnistes cause par
contre tant que tueur et utilise le mot
preuve j'attends toujours la preuve que
les espèces n'évolue pas preuve dont il
nous a dit qu'elle se chiffrait par
millions
bon il doit à rejeter bien comprendre
qu'il y en a certaines qui doivent être
difficile à comprendre mais quand même
s'il y en a des millions de ses preuves
elles sont où les doit y en avoir d
facile au moins dans le tas tu vois mais
bon je les attends toujours les
évolutionnistes continue à défendre que
les êtres vivants ont évolué cette
affirmation implique que des millions
d'espèces qui n'ont pu exister et encore
moins émergent se lavent cette
affirmation applique des millions
d'espèces qui n'ont pu exister encore
moins émerger
je comprends pas cette phrase enfin je
comprends pas ce que ça veut dire cette
affirmation implique des millions
d'espèces qui n'ont pu exister et encore
moins à émerger
bah ouais mais la craie la fin de la
fixité des espèces appli qui a plein
d'espèces dont on sait qu'elles ont
existé parce qu'on en a les fossiles
comme les trilobites et qui n'ont pas pu
émerger autrement que par évolution donc
je ne comprends pas cette phrase je
comprends pas ce que cette phrase est
censé vouloir dire pourtant les
évolutionnistes prétendent qu'elles se
sont développées au cours d'un processus
imaginaire l'évolution dont j'ai montré
tout à l'heure des preuves factuelles
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui qui ne peut
c'est qui ne peut s'expliquer ben si ça
s'explique très bien par la descendance
par modification et la sélection
naturelle ou toute autre forme de
sélection de type naturelles comme la
sélection sexuelle
ceci dit il a été prouvé qu'il est
impossible que des protéines puisse
naître a spontanément et à passer une
ligne sans que je m'en rende compte
pourtant selon la théorie de l'évolution
ce miracle a bel et bien eu lieu et la
protéine est né par hasard
bah non encore une fois le sel et les
créationnistes il aime beaucoup invoqué
le hasard enfin il aime beaucoup dire
que les défenseurs de l'évolution crois
que les espèces évoluent par hasard mais
non la sélection naturelle
c'est un processus sélectif
donc c'est pas le hasard le hasard il a
lu au niveau de la descendance avec
modification mais pas au niveau de la
sélection naturelle
donc ça n'a pas lieu par hasard tout ça
donc et le coup de l'adn contrairement à
lui je veux pas passer sous silence des
trucs importants donc le coût de l'adn
kiné qui est créé enfin le coût de l'adn
qui sort de nulle part parce
qu'effectivement il faut des protéines
pour faire de l'adn il faut de l'adn
pour faire des protéines
c'est pareil ils aiment beaucoup ça les
créationnistes sauf qu'on a une réponse
à ça et ça s'appelle le monde à arn
c'est à dire qu'avant il y avait de la
rn que la rn a donné l' adn
enfin que la rn permettait de coder les
protéines et que les protéines codées
l'adn enfin voilà avant il y avait la rn
arn qui est capable de jouer en fait et
la rn le truc c'est qu'il est capable à
la fois de jouer le rôle de protéines et
le rôle de molécules codante comme l'adn
donc voilà le monde à arn
c'est cadeau le monde à arn ces cadeaux
et on en a plein de preuves on en a
plein de preuves du monde à arn la
preuve la principale étant que la rn
existe aujourd'hui pourquoi l arn
existerait sachant qu'il faut prendre de
l'adn le transformer en arn puis le
transformer en protéines
pourquoi on passe pas directement de
l'adn aux protéines
la réponse bah c'est parce qu'il ya eu
un monde à arn avant donc la rn est une
condition importante de la et adn fait
toujours le pont en fête entre la
protéine et le l'adn donc voilà c'est
bon on a une explication très simple
pour ça mais encore faut-il prendre le
soin de vouloir se renseigner plutôt que
de copier coller des des créationnistes
américain pourtant selon la théorie de
la danse avait déjà lu
mais par hasard il est également
impossible que les organes elle de
cellules naissent ensemble par
coïncidence pareil personne n'a jamais
prétendu que les organes elle des
cellules sont apparus par coïncidence
une fois de plus appel au hasard qui ne
c'est un appel au hasard qu'on attribue
au niveau aux évolutionniste alors que
les évolutionnistes ne crois pas au
hasard puisque sélection naturelle c'est
cependant ce que veulent évolution banon
ce miracle se produisit un conduisant au
noyau de la cellule aux gènes à l'adn
aux enzymes et aux innombrables autres
structures complexes qui ne peuvent être
produites artificiellement aujourd'hui
même dans des conditions de laboratoire
contrôlé des enzymes on sait très bien
en faire en laboratoire
quoi d'autre des gènes on sait très bien
créer des on sait très bien assemblé des
des nucléotides pour en faire des gènes
et de l'adn enfin le diront c'est très
bien recréer tout ça en laboratoire il
n'y a pas de soucis 1
il n'y a pas de souci on a même réussi à
recréer un chromosome bactérien il ya
pas longtemps
c'est pour vous dire donc c'est à dire
un chromosome circulaire c'est vrai
qu'on s'est pas encore recréer les
chromosomes en forme de x là les vrais
chromosomes des cellules eucaryotes mais
on arrive même à recréer des chromosomes
maintenant donc va te faire [ __ ]
une fois de plus
oui et donc là le mot clé de tout ça
c'est la complexité c'est à dire qui a
effectivement il
il parle de mode il parle de molécules
et de phénomènes physiologiques complexe
et évidemment il nous dit que tout ça ne
peut pas apparaître
il va nous sortir certainement l'exemple
de si on met tout ça dans une tornade ça
va pas faire un avion là si on met des
parties d'avion dans une tornade ça va
pas faire un avion ces exemples
classiques à quoi je répondrai c'est
quoi la complexité
parce que la complexité c'est une notion
qui est purement humaine un caillou ça
t'as pas l'air d'être complexe tu
compares un caillou et une horloge
l'horloge toi en tant qu'humain a l'air
d'être l'élément le plus complexe parce
qu'il ya plein de rouages et tout ça le
caillou par contre quand on le regarde
au niveau moléculaire la chimie de ce
caillou elle est mis un milliard de fois
plus complexe que son horloge qui est
uniquement faite d'acier donc de deux
atomes techniquement l'alliage de deux
métaux donc
donc donc la complexité c'est quelque
chose qui est très très subjectif et
l'horloge qui est simple a été fait
artificiellement par contre le caillou
là ton morceau de granit la lui il est
apparu tout à fait naturellement dans
toute son incroyable complexité
chimiques
ces cristaux à l'intérieur de les
cristaux à l'intérieur du du granit dont
je suis sûr qu un créationniste oserait
dire qu'on n'arriverait pas à les
refaire en laboratoire par ailleurs un
dévoile à ses cristaux à la structure si
parfaite
eh bien ces cristaux de gras qui sont
dans le granit
ils sont 100 % naturel voilà donc la
complexité peut apparaître naturellement
il n'y a aucun souci là dedans
aucun absolument aucun ça ne dérange
aucun évolutionniste voilà
évidemment il nous ressort le truc du
hasard or selon la théorie de
l'évolution tous sont nés d'un hasard
aveugle ben non il n'est pas aveugle
sélection naturelle oh [ __ ] la
sélection naturelle c'est un crible
c'est un filtre ne laisse pas passer
tout c'est pas aveugle les
évolutionnistes ont passé au crible les
archives fossiles à la recherche d'une
quelconque trace de processus et de
changements impliquent est cependant
encore selon les évolutionnistes
un autre miracle s'est produit toute
trace dans des archives le fossile ont
disparu toutes les traces dans les
archives aux fossiles ont disparu ben au
contraire c'est toi que ça arrange là
voilà tu as l'air de dire qu'en gros ça
arrange les évolutionnistes que les
traces ont disparu ben non là c'est toi
que ça arrange et alors pourquoi
pourquoi ça arrangera les
évolutionnistes
crétin les conditions requises pour la
formation d'une cellule sont trop
importantes en termes de quantité pour
pouvoir accepter le hasard comme
explication les cellules c'est trop
complexe pour se former tout seul dit il
et pourtant dans ton corps en ce moment
même des milliers de cellules sont en
train de se former tout seul comme des
grandes
c'est trop compliqué l'adn pour se
former tout seul et pourtant c'est ce
que ton t cellules fond tout le temps
elle crée de l'adn tout seul comme des
grandes
donc arrête de dire des conneries
1 arrête de dire des conneries c'est
juste que tu refuse de croire qui a pu y
avoir un truc avant l'adn qui a créé
l'adn voilà c'est juste ça ton problème
barben sauf que les évolutionnistes
ils ont une théorie pour ça ça s'appelle
le monde le monde à arn
cependant il n'est pas nécessaire
d'expliquer la situation avec ses
détails les évolutionnistes se trouve
dans une impasse
avant même d'en avant même d'atteindre
le stade de cellules
c'est parce que la probabilité de la
formation par harald du seul protéines
élément essentiel à la cellule et matic
et mathématiquement 2 0 oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai la fois la probabilité de la
formation par hasard d'une seule c'est
d'une seule protéine élément essentiel
de la cellule est effectivement 2-0 sur
un temps court sur un temps court mais
l'expérience de mineurs qui a été fait
dans les années 50 et qui a été
reproduite depuis donc l'expérience de
miller et qui a été reproduite et qu'il
n'arrête pas d'être reproduite avec de
nouveaux paramètres expérience oui mais
de miller voilà donc l'expérience de
miller ça vous dit peut-être rien mais
si je vous montre l'image
l'expérience 2000 heure apparemment il
ya un miller qui voit là c'est cette
fameuse image là là ça doit normalement
vous parlez donc l'expérience de miller
s'est on balance des composants de
protéines dans un milieu où on balance
aussi de l'énergie sous forme
d'électricité pour mimer des éclairs
mais bon ça peut être de l'énergie
solaire ça peut être n'importe quoi on
balance les composants des protéines
donc comme vous voyez un mélange d'eau
d'ammoniac de méthane et d'hydrogène et
avec l'électricité on ressort des acides
aminés qui sont les composants de base
des protéines et évidemment nous ne
sommes pas capables de vivre pendant des
millions d'années pour voir si cela va
former une protéine 1
on est capable de faire tourner sa queue
pendant quelques heures quelques jours
quelques mois même tout au plus mais on
ne va pas faire tourner ça pendant des
millions d'années
or la vie elle est apparue d'après le
registre fossile dont il nous dit
d'ailleurs qu'il n'existe pas
le registre fossile la vie nous dit que
l'état nous dit que la vie est apparue
il ya entre 3 8 et 4 milliards d'années
ce qui veut dire sachant que la terre à
4,5 milliards d'années ça veut dire
qu'il ya 500 millions d'années pendant
lesquelles ces protéines ont baigné dans
une pub est niée alors c'est 500
millions d'années il ya quand même une
partie où la terre était boules de magma
donc on va pas mais il ya au moins 100
millions d'années et même 50 millions da
et même un million d'années ça suffit je
veux dire un million d'années on se rend
même pas compte de la quel point c'est
long je dirais vous avez du jus qui
marine dans une terre qui bouillonne en
gros avec des éclairs peu partout avec
le soleil qui bombardent pas ce qu'il y
a pas d'atmosphère donc il ya de
l'énergie là dedans qui est balancé dans
le système et vous avez une terre
primitive avec ce bouillon là qu'ils
arrêtent pas d'être muet par une énergie
constante
c'est l'expérience de miller mais sur
une planète entière et pendant plusieurs
millions d'années
ben je veux dire si on arrive à faire
quelques acides aminés en quelques
heures
on finira forcément par faire des
protéines je veux dire c'est affirmer le
contraire c'est affirmer qu'une d'une
n'ai pas fait de grandes salles c'est
des conneries c'est de la connerie pure
et simple
voilà
suivant la principale raison de cela
elle a nécessité d'autres protéines
d'être présente pour la formation d'une
protéine ce qui élimine complètement la
possibilité de la formation par hasard
ben comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
oui mais une protéine ça peut la rn peut
avoir fonction de protéines
donc on peut avoir une protéine formé
par delà ce fait et puis d'ailleurs
c'est complètement con enfin je veux
dire en plus tout à l'heure je vous ai
dit l'argument normalement c'est de
l'argument créationnistes de base
normalement c2c d'évoquer la tautologie
qui consiste à dire que pour faire de
l'adn il faut une protéine et pour faire
une protéine il faut de l'adn et là ils
nous passent directement de pour faire
une protéine il faut une autre protéine
donc en plus il utilise même pas
l'argument comme il faut donc je sais
même pas pourquoi je m'emmerde a essayé
de demel damon qu'est ce guignol
il est même pas capable d'utiliser le
bon argument créationnistes comme il
faut pourquoi je perds mon temps avec
toi tu es du menu fretin se fait en
lui-même est suffisant pour éliminer
l'affirmation évolutionniste du hasard
ça tombe bien
personne aucun évolutionniste n'affirme
le hasard aucun aucun 0 tout le monde
parle de sélection naturelle
pour résumer on arrive à la fin a on
arrive à la fin est ça vous donne
presque envie de croire de croire en
dieu là on est enfin la fin lille où il
le miracle existe il ma converti ça y
est il ya enfin un moment où il la ferme
non il ya d'autres articles qui viennent
après donc vous imaginez il a toute une
mitraillade de deux postes facebook
comme ça qu'il a postés pendant des
années je n'ose même pas imaginer si je
devais passer mon temps à débloquer tout
ça quelle horreur
quelle horreur bon alors résumons grand
les protéines ne peuvent pas être
synthétisés sans les enzymes qui sont
des protéines tête de noeud lycée il
connaît même pas la différence entre une
enzyme est une protéine je veux dire il
y en a pas les enzymes sont des
protéines à chier les protéines ne
peuvent pas être synthétisés sans les
enzymes et les enzymes sont toutes des
protéines
argument de merde puisque comme j'ai dit
les normalement c'est l'adn a besoin des
protéines la protéine ont besoin de
l'adn pour être synthétisés donc c'est
même pas le bon argument qui utilisent
la donc de quoi tu parles
et puis argument qui ne marche pas
puisque on pense qu'au départ il y avait
un monde adn arn pardon que la rn
pouvait à la fois synthétiser plus
darren mais qu'il pouvait aussi jouer le
rôle de protéines donc à la base il y
avait la rn et la rn est une molécule
plus simple que l'adn et cet arn a pu
être lui-même synthétiser à partir d'une
molécule plus anciennes qui ne qui pour
le coup on n'a pas de preuves de cette
de l'existence de cette molécule donc
faut quand même aussi admettre nos
limitations dans le cas de cet argument
là pour le monde arn on a de bonnes
preuves pour la molécule qui a avant ça
est l'ancêtre de la rn là par contre on
n'a pas de preuves mais mais
on sort du domaine des évolutionnistes
parce que les évolutionnistes
ils expliquent l'origine de la
biodiversité donc de la diversité
actuelle or
or ce l'origine de la diversité actuelle
ne peut pas remonter plus loin que
l'ancêtre en commun de toutes les
espèces actuelles qui qu'on appelle
lucas pour last universal comme un de
ces stores donc on peut pas remonter
plus loin que ça or le monde à arn on
est déjà bien avant lui qu'a donc on est
déjà hors du domaine des évolutionnistes
on est du domaine des biochimistes la
ville aux chimistes qui peuvent étudier
ça en étant évolutionniste ou pas
d'ailleurs ça poserait pas problème
puisque on est dans un univers de
purement de molécules voilà mais par
contre si la vie
si la vie existe enfin vu que la vie
existe et que cette vie est d'origine
miraculeuse
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ait fait des
mêmes atom que le reste
grande question ça
vient le doubs vient la spécificité de
la vie
si on admet pas l'évolution parce que
dans un contexte évolutive la vie est
originaire du nom vivant non vivants qui
a fini par qu'ils n'étaient que sous
forme de réaction chimique réaction
chimique qui se sont complexifiées
jusqu'au point où il y a eu une auto
réplication d'une certaines molécules
l'auto réplication de cette certaines
molécules c'est bah c'est tout
simplement l'ancêtre de l'aed l'adn en
fait l'ancêtre de la rn même
donc c'est tout simplement l'ancêtre de
notre adn parce que l'adn sa propriété
c'est de se répliquer lui même et pour
ça il a construit des grandes machines
qu'on appelle des êtres vivants ces
grandes machines n'ont qu'un but
reproduire plus d'adr mais à la base il
y avait qu une molécule qui étaient
capables de se reproduire
et justement par sélection naturelle
cette molécule s'est complexifié et à
complexifier son mécanisme de
reproduction
donc tout ce qu'on a besoin à la base
c'est juste d'une molécule capable de se
reproduire
la sélection naturelle fait le reste
parce qu'elle va sélectionner les
molécules qui se reproduisent le mieux
le plus vite en plus grande quantité le
plus efficacement
donc tout ce qu'on a besoin pour que la
vie apparaissent c'est juste d'une
molécule capable de se reproduire c'est
tout la vie c'est juste ça
c'est juste ça c'est fondamentalement
extrêmement simple
donc oui c'est un cadre qui est purement
théorique mais c'est un cadre qui est
purement théorique mais redoutablement
efficace par sa simplicité
vous prenez vous prenez pas mais bon
comme je le dit de toute façon l'origine
de la vie et au delà du bien au delà de
la théorie de l'évolution
la théorie de l'évolution ne fait que
expliquer l'origine de la biodiversité
pas l'origine de la vie donc de toutes
façons l'argument un déjà on peut le
balayer sous le tapis en mode ça
concerne pas les évolutionnistes
arguments deux environ 100 protéines
doivent être présentes pour la synthèse
d'une seule protéine
c'est censé être un résumé de tout
l'article parce qu'il a commencé avec
les fossiles et matin il nous parle que
de protéines
bref environ 100 protéines doivent être
présentes pour la synthèse d'une seule
protéine
il faut donc qu'il y ait déjà des
protéines pour la formation des
protéines
c'est le même argument 2 c'est le même
que l'argument 1 il rajoute juste des
protéines c'est tout l'adn fabrique des
enzymes qui synthétise des protéines les
protéines ne peuvent pas être
synthétisés sans adn l'adn est donc
également nécessaires pour la formation
des protéines bas c'est exactement ce
que je vais me dire encore une fois tu
as enfin trouvé le bon argument jean gus
c'est bien c'est bien ça il ya quand
même fallu que tu sortes deux arguments
qui marchent pas avant mais c'est bien
tu as fini par trouver le bon argument
c'est dommage j'ai déjà des bonnes que
cet argument bien avant et arguments 4
tout les ans donc c'est tout
les organes elle de la cellule ont des
tâches importantes dans la synthèse des
protéines
en d'autres termes la formation des
protéines une cellule parfaite et
pleinement opérationnelle doit exister
avec tous ses organes elle non bah oui
allez tuer les bactéries les bactéries
elles n'ont pas d'organites fin
d'organes elle si tu veux
les bactéries c'est juste un sac avec de
l'adn de dents et un peu de protéines il
n'ya pas d'organe elle est pourtant elle
arrive très bien à fabriquer de l'adn et
des protéines peuvent très bien se
reproduire
ta gueule une méconnaissance à ce point
de la biologie ça mérite juste un ta
gueule
sa une à compétence incroyable à un
manque de une fainéantise intellectuelle
remarquable j'arrive à démontrer que
l'évolution n'existe pas générique de
fin face au manque de preuves les
darwinistes persiste au contraire à
utiliser des méthodes frauduleuses
méthodes frauduleuses il en a il en a
présenté que deux ça concernait les
fossiles ça concernait pas l'adn donc
voilà donc en plus tu es hors sujet j'ai
envie de dire et à plus les deux
méthodes frauduleuses que tu as
préserver les deux fossiles frauduleuse
c'était pas des fraudes c'était des
erreurs et en plus ça daté d'il ya 120
ans donc il ya un peu prescription mais
le public devient de plus en plus
conscients du fait que l'évolution est
enseigné pour des raisons idéologiques
et non scientifique
contrairement aux contrairement à ton
pavé qui n'a pas du tout été fait pour
des raisons idéologiques ou religieuses
l'un évidemment et avec ça on va mettre
un petit bonhomme en colère dessus parce
que sa mamie colère voilà je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si
vous êtes encore là et je vous dis à
très bientôt pour une des nouvelles
heures de souffrance
merci